Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
I'm so sorry for being late, guys.
I'm really sorry.
We had... I had to walk.
Dad, I was warming up earlier, and the matches went on a little later than I thought it was gonna go on.
Sorry, my voice is slowly dead.
I'm gonna take, like, rest days the next two... I think, like, for the next two days...
Monday and Tuesday, I'm definitely gonna take a rest day.
So, um...
Uh, cause my voice is dying.
I did too many double streams.
I'm gonna get... Let me grab a cough drop real quick.
Anyway, um, so the trend... We don't have matches until 6 p.m.
because, uh, um, um, we're not playing first.
So, uh, we're gonna be... We're gonna warm up a little bit with Mac or Slash Alberlele.
So, um, the rest of the team isn't here yet.
Uh, so I think Surefour is playing Deadlock, and, like, our other teammates are asleep, and I don't know where Aztec is, so, like...
So, like, I don't know.
I don't know.
Um, anyway, um, uh, uh, so, like, uh, you know, he's literally streaming Deadlock right now.
Uh, so, yeah, I just got back from Walking Dead.
I had to pick some maps as well.
We're doing map picks and stuff.
I don't know.
I don't really know what maps to do or, like, if we do attack or defense.
So, I was literally just, I was just, like, asking Mac, and he was like, I don't fucking know.
I literally just played the game today, and I was like, I don't know.
I don't fucking know which is attack or which is T-sided or not.
So, we were, uh, we were picking maps and everything, so that's why it took me a bit, uh, to get here.
I'm really sorry for being late, but, like, games don't really start anyway.
We're just warming... Most... The most we're gonna do is just warm up.
Um, he was telling me, apparently, some teams were forfeiting, um, because they were fighting against teams that were, um, that were, that have been playing Stranova for, like, months now that have been, like, you know, because Stranova is out in other countries and,
uh, but not in NA.
So, like, there were teams that have been playing Stranova for months and then, um, apparently, Mac told me there were teams that forfeited because they were like, this is bullshit, so we're just gonna... We're not even gonna play anymore.
And I was like, holy shit, that's fucking crazy.
I was like, oh my god, what?
So, um, so I guess, like, matches, um, are gonna be fast.
I don't know how my team's gonna go because, like I said, we have every type of FPS player, not just FPS, but we have every type of, like, um, um, shooter player except for Valorant.
So, like, because, like, so, like, this game is all, it's a tactical shooter and it's all about util, utility, um, and, like, uh, I'm scared because, um, the second team we're fighting against are, like, Valorant players.
So, uh, so, and I don't know.
I think some, they might have, you know, they might have Shinova experience as well.
So, we're freaking, we'll see.
We'll see.
We'll see how it goes.
I'm pretty sure the second team, yeah, the second team we're playing are Valorant players.
So, um, we'll see how it goes.
Um, anyway, um, anyway, huge shout out to Shinova for sponsoring me.
Uh, they reached out and wanted me to join this tournament and decided to sponsor me.
So, please, um, if you want to support, oh, yeah, I just realized, like, I pinned the message that, guys, mod, do you have my message that I'm, oh, there you go.
I accidentally, I accidentally, like, unpinned my sponsor thing.
Anyway, um, so, if you guys want to help out the stream, you can download the game for some free rewards, by the way.
You pre-register or sign up now.
You can get some free rewards where you can unlock things.
There's gacha in this game as well.
So, I'll show you guys real quick.
Um, but yes, it helps out, it helps the stream out a lot, um, if you click on the link.
So, please check it out.
Anyway, I'll show you guys Shinova.
So, um, anyway, so, um, there's some, I'll be playing Catgirl, uh, Michelle, uh, I'll be playing Michelle, which is me.
I'm playing her, and then I'll also be playing, um, I'll be playing Celestia.
I see, I don't know, we haven't really talked about who's playing what, but I assume nobody in my team wants to heal.
So, like, I will be, I'll, I'll be the grown adult here, because I know Surefour, Surefour wants to be Sniper.
And so, um, so, I'll play the I'll play the healer on attack, and then I'll play, uh, Michelle on defense, so Retro Doki on defense.
And then, um, I think Albert Lele is playing Audrey, and then I don't know anybody else, like, I, I don't know what everybody else is gonna play.
Also, there's Gacha.
Yes.
Also, I have a lot of money, because I got sponsored.
So, um, so, we have a lot, so there's Gacha, so I could literally, like, Gacha, right?
I don't know how to do this Gacha.
Is it this?
Oh, okay, and then we draw.
So, let's, might as well, might as well roll, like, I got free Gacha tickets anyway.
Like, we might as well, it's free.
What does the orc draw?
Do you think I know?
Like, I think red is the rare, right?
Oh, that's a nice...
Oh, you're not... Bro, they're all of them are, like, they're all, like, guns.
I... Oh, nice.
Oh, hey!
That's me!
That's my gun!
I'll play.
I'll put it on, and then the rest don't matter.
Oh, hey!
Oh, she's cute.
Lime is... Lime color is cute.
All right, here we go.
Time to main Audrey.
All right, purple.
Purple.
I'm skipping.
Oh!
Why did I skip?
Nice.
All right.
Why did I skip?
The moment, the moment...
I didn't think I'd get it!
Like, I didn't think I'd hit it.
All right, nice.
I didn't think I'd actually hit the gacha pool.
In fact, I didn't know.
You skipped yourself.
I didn't fucking know.
I'm stupid.
I was like, no, there's no way.
There's no way I hit those.
Oh my god, that's actually crazy.
That's why you never skip.
Oh shit, sweet.
Okay, nice.
That's cool.
I got my... Oh shit, I got gold.
Which gold is that?
Nice, I got another gold.
What do I get?
Who's here?
Again?
Are you fucking... Okay, I might as well put it on.
I...
Why do I get it again?
Are you serious?
There's so many other gold skins!
There's so many gold skins and I get her again.
Okay, by so many, there's also two other, but still.
Like, there's literally two other ones.
Like, how the fuck do I get it again?
Let's go gambling.
At least I get to see it this time.
At least, at least I get to see the roll this time.
Oh, there's three reds.
Oh, there's more pity.
The more you roll, the more pity you get.
See, there's three more.
Oh shit.
I swear to god.
I swear to fucking god.
I...
Oh, it's a gun this time.
Oh, hey!
Oh, fucking...
Are you serious?
How do I... how is it all that's...
There's so many other golds!
There's... oh!
Oh my god, I hit it.
I hit those.
Okay, what did I get?
Same gun skin this time.
They cannot give me another, another gun.
Oh, wait, is this for him?
Oh my god, I got the legendaries!
Oh my god, I got everything I planned.
All right, I'm done.
I'm done.
All right.
I'm done rolling.
How many more?
Oh, I literally... that was my last roll.
Oh my god, that's great.
That's literally my last roll.
Oh, that's good.
All right, let's see.
I'm gonna make sure I have... oh, nice.
I'm glad it was my last roll too.
Um, customize.
Um...
Wait, where's the gun skin?
Oh, wait, weapon skin.
There we go.
I might as well... Oh, I have it on already.
Okay, nice.
Do I have my... do I have a weapon skin for her?
Oh, I do.
I might as well, like...
Like, we're here anyway, I might as well.
All right.
Um...
Oh, wait, I rolled.
Wait, okay.
Um...
Okay, uh, I think we are...
Uh, I think we're good.
All right.
So, this is basically, um, this is a tactical shooter, but like with, uh, with anime girls.
And, um, so you guys know how tactical shooters work.
It's literally that.
Like, I don't know how else to explain it.
We played it before, guys.
We played it before.
So, like, it's...
It's very... it's based... I don't think much has changed since the last time we played it.
Um, but yes, if you guys want to check out the game, you can click on the link right now to download the game, I believe, and, um, and, uh, get some free rewards, like, pre-register and everything.
So, yeah, I'm super excited.
Oh, do I have some... Oh, hey, nice.
Congratulations.
Oh, I get an... I got, like, a special icon.
Okay, I'm gonna... I'm deafened.
Hello?
Are you ready?
I sense... I asked to join your team.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me in.
All right, I'm ready.
How did you change your banner?
Uh...
Well...
Okay, well, I guess we'll find out later.
Yep, we'll find out.
I guess... we can only play one game anyway, so...
That's... dang, we were only able to play one game.
All right.
Um, where's the rest of our team?
Um, they are... we don't know.
Mac and I, we, like... Oh, yeah, I forgot to put you on screen, too.
Mac and I, we, like, we've been warming up, like, he's been warming up for, like, hours.
I've been warming up, like, what, two hours, I think.
Two hours.
And, um...
Um, when we were warming up, we saw the... our enemy team has been, like, um, in the server warming up together for, like...
basically, like, you know...
Uh, for, like, an hour and a half, so they're more locked in than us, like, that's all.
They're... they're very locked in compared to us.
Yeah, I'm sure it'll be fine.
Yeah, yeah, sure.
Okay, to be fair, to be fair, he's playing Deadlock, which is sort of similar to Shinova because it's third person.
So, like, yeah, so, like, it's almost the same thing.
Yeah, yeah, basically.
Yeah, yeah, like, like, as long as he's playing Sniper, nothing's different with Sniper, you know, like...
Sniper is, like, you're sniping, like, there's not much different.
Uh-huh.
All right.
I'm sure he's definitely playing Vindicta in Deadlock, too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Still one-tricking, like, McGuinness or something.
Okay, my god, what is he doing right now?
Every time I run into him, that guy is just spamming McGuinness.
I know, I'm pretty sure that's what he's playing.
Oh my god, I hope he...
Well, let's see.
All right, guys, we're playing a pub, by the way, chat.
This is a pub, so we're just warming up right now.
We are the two players that...
sort of wanna... sort of not wanna get shit on.
We wanna be... oh, they're A, they're A.
Got them.
I have wind on there, too.
Um, they're on me.
Killed one mid.
They're all A, they're all... oh, there's a lot of them.
I got him.
Got him?
There's people on my other... who are next to me.
Our teammate died trying to save me.
Okay, I'm gonna do something dumb.
Help me!
Oh, I can't.
Our teammate doesn't care.
Oh my god, there's three!
Oh my god, I tried to... I'm never helping again.
I made a mistake.
Helping was... is a crime.
Never be a team player, chat.
Never be a team player.
Oh, it's a 1v1, but he's so low.
It's not over yet.
Is he not gonna push?
Oh, he's not.
He might plant.
Thanks for saving me.
Oh, he is planting.
That's ballsy.
Should be a free dub.
I think I got too many res me healers, so...
Oh, it's a sniper, so yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, nice!
We should put this guy on our team.
Yeah, he seems locked in.
Yeah, yeah, he seems more locked in than the rest of us.
We might as well...
Okay, I raised... I raised up Mac a little bit on Discord.
Wait, he has a katana?
Oh my god, he... he paid for this game.
By the way, Mac, like since he... you know, we have accounts that are like unlocked and everything.
Um, you know how we have everything?
Katana, you gotta play to win.
Yeah, you gotta like play to unlock a katana.
Wait, the secondary?
Yeah, I think so.
I think so.
I'm pretty sure, right?
Unless, um, unless I'm wrong.
Oh no, all I know is my account had someone else's name on it when I first started playing.
I'm waning.
Oh, there be?
Okay, I'm heading over.
I'm flying over.
Okay, we're coming back.
We're running over.
Oh, you're so fucking...
I'm heading over here.
I'm here.
They're coming over.
He's coming over.
I hit one for... I hit like two for a hundred.
Nice.
I have a win.
I have a win on them.
Or on me.
He's fucking burning me.
What the fuck?
He actually... He just ran in the burn.
Bro.
Alright, back at it again with this person.
Oh shit.
Okay, maybe I should get the burn.
Oh my god.
Well, he has to do it now or...
I hate this guy.
He has to do it now or... Oh, he's getting body blocked by the enemy team.
No, he doesn't get it.
It's too late.
No, he's got it.
It's too free.
Oh, he got it.
Oh, okay.
Hey, let's send him an invite to join our team.
Yeah, sure.
You're good on deadlock, bro.
You got it.
Deadlock.
Yeah, you're good.
No, no, we need him on sniper.
All right, let's roll.
We gotta flip the coin with the last two teammates and be like, hey, for the sake of our ego...
We need this guy.
He actually feels like he's been playing this for a while.
At least I got a kill.
Oh, at least I'm not bottom fragger.
Who could that be?
Unbound my scoreboard button.
Oh,
they're mid.
Oh, wait, no, they're not mid.
Oh, they're there.
Um, probably setting my turret in there.
I fucked up my turret.
Guys, I need you to know I was doing so well earlier in the warm-up with Mac.
Like, I don't know what happened to me.
I don't know what happened to me.
That is not the Gront Rewatch Max Bot.
I literally carried this fucker.
It's the stream debuff.
Every time I stream...
Every time I stream, it just hits different.
I just fuck around more when I'm streaming.
Oh shit, nice.
Look at that, we won.
We won.
Okay, now I'm locked in for real.
I'm for real locked in this time.
I'm just throwing matches for views, exactly.
Yeah, it's content.
It's content, guys.
Okay, I'm locked out.
What the fuck?
Someone's arrived.
Who is that?
Is that Surefour?
That's Surefour.
I fucking knew it.
Only you have a soundboard.
What's wrong with my fucking soundboard, huh?
You got a fucking problem, or what?
You have a problem.
You don't use it often.
You should use it every time on stream.
My soundboard?
Yeah.
Yeah, well, no, I just play that song on stream every now and then, anyways.
Wait, is that song like DMCA-able?
Is that?
I don't know.
Oh my gosh, I swear.
Wait, he just got us both striked.
I swear to god, if that song...
I highly doubt that that song is DMCA, but...
If I lose my...
If I lose...
Hey, if you lose your ad revenue or whatever...
Get shit on, that's all I'm saying.
Okay, have you played Chernobyl at all?
Yeah, we played that one tournament.
Yeah, but I mean like recently.
Like, is it too warm up at all?
I'm in the practice range right now.
That's something.
That's something, yeah.
I'll make sure she doesn't die.
You want to see my practice range aim training?
Yeah, no, we're in.
We're streaming right now.
What do you mean?
How could we see it?
No, I'm linking a clip in chat.
Oh.
All right, uh...
That's what I was up to.
Oh my god.
All right, you're playing sniper, right?
Yeah, I'm just gonna only pick snipers.
Okay.
Yeah, we all assumed that was what's gonna happen.
Yeah.
All right, I mean we have time.
You want to join the warm-up?
We have time for a warm-up game.
All right.
We just need to win three more rounds and then we can do it.
So you guys are owning.
Well, our team is owning.
I forgot to set up.
My name is in Chinese.
You can change your nickname in the profile.
Yeah, my name is Zaiwu when I started out.
How do I change my nickname?
You go to your profile and then there's a section called change nickname.
Oh, they're A.
They're A.
Or yeah, they're A.
Profile.
Career?
Um, top left.
Top left.
Yeah, that's how you do it.
Oh, they planned it.
What's that?
Oh, I got slowed and blinded.
What if I just left it?
I mean you can.
Like it's a choice.
Wait, can I spend all the currency?
Yeah, you can.
Yeah.
Yippee, I'm gonna gamble.
I gotcha too.
You can gacha like eight times.
I have 87.
Uh, yeah, yeah, 10.
Yeah, you can gacha 10 times because you put 10 in there each time to unlock 10.
Wait, which one do I press?
You just press the right button.
Whatever color that right button was.
What's the difference between yellow and blue?
It's increase and decrease.
So like you take a card away.
So you gacha less things basically.
Oh, I didn't know that.
I just made like weird shapes.
I don't think it mattered.
The numbers increase?
What do you mean?
Yeah, I thought it was like a cosmetic increase.
Yeah, it's like 1 to 10 pulls.
Like you get to... you choose between 1 or 10 pulls.
It's literally gacha.
I got a purple!
Two purples!
Oh nice, nice.
Oh, they're AA, BBB.
I don't use either of those.
Again.
Then you just have bad gacha luck.
What can I say?
I'm not a lucky person.
I know.
I got a yellow!
Wait, that's good.
That's how you say you're not lucky.
I want the red one.
Yeah, it took me eight fucking pulls to get the red one.
Did you get the gun or the character skin?
I got Inari's shadow.
The fuck does that mean?
Nah, nah, it's about... I'm talking about the red.
The one Doki got.
Oh yeah, I got red.
I got a red skin.
Did you get the gun skin or the character?
I got character.
I got the Celeste red skin.
The rose one.
I got the gun.
I think like we have a guarantee red because we did eight pulls.
I got another yellow!
I got double with the yellow.
I got two dupes.
Oh shit.
I need to pick a side.
I got the sniper rifle skin!
They wanted Kochi street.
What the fuck is Kochi street?
Uh What the fuck does that mean?
What the fuck is that street called?
Oh that street.
I don't know.
Guys, do you want to attack or defense?
Do you want to attack or defense?
Yeah, flip a coin.
Fuck it.
It's a three-sided map.
It's a map with three sites.
Oh, it's that one.
Which one should we do?
Attack or defense for that?
Defense is better for sniper.
All right, we'll do defense.
I got another yellow!
All right.
They're like little sperms going into the color.
I got a dupe!
Should have been luckier, surefour.
Should have been luckier.
I'm not fucking lucky.
There's three chances at reds here.
Of course I get a red, right?
Yeah.
Sperm, go to the correct egg.
Guess not.
I'm rezzing.
We literally just need to win one round and then we're out.
Yellow!
I'm going to help our team.
I'm gonna help sad boonbox.
Oh, that's poor guy.
Poor guy.
It's very sad.
Sniper rifle!
Oh, wait, that's good.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
I didn't see him.
Yeah, I got flanked.
Oh, please if you guys win this we don't have to play another round.
Red!
Guys, do you even think they'll notice your sniper cosmetic?
Rose knight!
Celestia!
Oh, I got that too!
You're not playing her.
She's not sniper.
It's fucking bullshit.
Oh, you're fucking dead.
There's no way.
Bro!
I got the... I got the top gun skin though.
That's why I'm at her.
Yo, they're just guarding the bot.
What if they flank you in the back?
Wouldn't that be funny?
Oh, no, they're all three there.
All three of them are in front of you.
I saw them.
This is the other sniper, isn't it?
I thought instantly.
Limited offer.
I'm gonna have the bomb.
Wait, can I spend the currency?
Yeah, you can.
You can literally spend as much as you want as long as...
I can do whatever I want.
You can do whatever you want, true4.
You can literally do whatever the fuck you want.
I can do whatever I want.
Okay, slash root.
All right, I have bomb.
Where are we going?
We're all at different areas.
I think it's just an A rush.
All right.
Oh my god, they want me to roll again.
Okay.
Does anyone know if the other game's done yet?
Like how many games they have left?
Does anyone know?
I don't know.
Fuck.
Oh shit.
I hope you're guarding this.
I love gambling.
Oh my god.
I'm fine.
I'm not fine.
It was not good.
Oh, it's time to hold everything.
It's not okay.
One more, one more.
I'm not moving.
Yay!
Wait, what did he say?
He said he loves you.
To who?
I couldn't even hear the beginning.
I just thought, oh shit.
Someone said they love you?
I was like, who the fuck said that?
All right, uh, Trifor, what's your tag?
What's your numbers?
No, it doesn't do username.
It does numbers.
Oh, so you hate me.
I mean, the game hates you.
How do I do the tag?
The ID?
All right, here.
I gave you mine.
I copied.
And then... I copied.
I posted it.
Okay, I forgot that.
Oh, there you can be.
I forgot.
I was like, everybody could see it too.
So...
Yeah, just leak it.
It's fine.
I'll leak, I'll leak Trifor and my ID.
So then we both get uh, spammed.
It's like... I don't want to get spammed.
Well, it's too late.
I already leaked it on stream.
Trifor, pick a map.
Pick a map you like the best.
We got map pick.
You think I know the fucking maps?
Well, I don't know the map either.
Pick a map.
I'm gonna pick a shitty map.
Pick the one that's good for sniper rifle.
Bro, I don't... they might do attack.
They might choose like defense so you can't...
Well, I'm gonna snipe on offense too.
Okay, I mean true.
Um, wait, where is...
Why can't I... How do I change the girl on my main screen?
Accept my friend request.
You can't.
I don't think so.
This is fucking bullshit.
All right.
I'll just write whichever is the sniper.
Whichever is the sniper.
Yeah, you have to code to add friend.
And then... What the fuck?
That's weird.
I accepted it.
All right, and then uh, invite to team.
Ignore their requests for five minutes.
Nice.
All right.
Wait, you have to look at my clip though.
That's what I was doing.
Okay, all right, uh, let's see.
I'll look at your clip.
Okay, sure.
Yeah, I just wrote whichever is the sniper map and they just handed us a map.
What are you doing?
That's good for me.
What the fuck were you doing?
What are you doing?
Oh my god.
Did I have... Oh, thank god they didn't hear it.
What do you mean?
I didn't hear it.
Fucking your mic.
What the fuck?
Is it like a webcam mic?
I didn't fucking hear it.
Is that a fucking webcam mic?
What the fuck is that?
No, I added uh, on my microphone.
I added a uh, what did I do?
What did you do?
I added a compressor and gain.
Oh, the why?
I also, I also sang the mine diamond song.
Oh my, okay guys, um, if you guys want to watch his clip, I'll link it right now, but like be warned.
That's all I'll say.
All right, queue us up.
We have like time for one game.
He's very loud.
All right.
I'm not.
Okay, from this clip.
Yes, you are.
Okay, dude.
All right.
Uh, back, queue us up.
Oh, he's afk.
Oh, he's fucking deafened.
Oh, he's literally the leader.
What is he?
Oh, queue us up.
How many, how many cans flew off your desk during that mic check?
Be honest.
Only two.
It sounded like at least four.
Uh, there's a lot of cans in my room.
Oh, we got into the game.
Nice.
Enter link.
Who's this fucker that didn't enter?
Who the fuck is this guy?
He's deafened.
Jokey, that clip made me deaf.
I told, I warned you guys.
I told you guys he was very, I gave you guys a warning.
It wasn't loud.
I gave you guys that warning.
Why do they have a main stage and a sub stage?
I think sub stage is for, I think we're on both main stages.
So like, dude, I'm gonna make up for it right now.
Because there's two, two matches that are going on at the same time.
But why did they put us, why did they give us both main stage?
Like,
that's fucked.
They gave us both the main stages.
Yeah, because we're poggers.
My neighbors are yelling me because I had my windows open and that was on speakers.
Thanks, Jerkboy.
Thank you.
Hey, you're welcome.
That's what I'm here for.
All right, guys, I, how's the sound now, guys?
How's the audio balancing now?
All right, all right, I'll, I'll take the spike.
Why the fuck is this?
Is this the, oh, this is the, is this the map we're playing first?
Uh, yeah.
No.
No, wait, no, wait.
I don't remember.
Wait, did we pick a three-lane map?
Yeah, we did.
This might be it.
This is literally what he wanted.
Okay, well, we don't want to go A, I don't think.
This is what he wanted.
Where do I follow?
I'm following, we're going, we're going A.
That's where everybody is.
Maybe we shouldn't have picked this map.
Eh, we'll be fine.
We'll get a dub.
We'll get at least one dub, right, guys?
Just one dub.
Wait, they're saying we can now enter the match to prepare.
Oh, um, we're missing two players.
One guy I think is still sleeping because he's EU.
I have C, by the way.
You have C?
Okay.
Wait, that guy's won.
Yeah, well, I just downed someone.
I'm planting, cover me.
There's someone to my left.
Sniper Diff.
I might die.
I might just play this guy.
Oh, shit, let's go!
Fuck every other character I've played before.
Who are you playing?
Uh, I don't even know his name, but he looks like Dante.
Okay, now you decide to swap after you fucking grinded this all?
Oh my god.
After you grinded all of these?
I one tapped a guy in the head and it felt really nice.
That's who I was going to play, but I like snipers.
Yeah, this is a 1v1.
This is a sniper, but it's like a DMR.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I've got like a catalyst wall.
Oh, that guy!
Yeah, I know what you're talking about.
He's got the mirror realm shit.
Yeah, he's got the mirror realm, yeah.
It's like, welcome to my domain.
Domain expansion.
Dollar General Catalyst.
Alright.
How'd that not hit?
Peeking in.
Alright, I'm walking through the wall.
I'm walking through the wall now.
Left side!
That's the wrong grenade.
I'm taking high ground.
I'm fucking lost in this wall.
That guy's one shot.
Behind you!
Where am I?
Oh my god.
I'm taking out the cat!
I came out of my wall into a smoke grenade and then walked into a real wall.
For about five seconds.
It's fun.
We gotta win this fast, guys.
Where's like three of our...
Where's two of our other teammates?
I don't know, team captain.
Where are they?
I don't fucking know.
One of them is online right now.
But where's the...
The other one was in a general channel above this channel I saw.
Dude, let's switch it up.
Let's go C, boys.
Wait, why did it...
Yeah, I'm down.
C was dope.
Alright, I'm homing over.
We can...
We can do this, I believe.
Oh my god, I just upskirted.
Oh my god.
How do you feel?
Nothing.
Are you okay?
What do you mean, nothing?
Split my site in half.
Wait, it doesn't work.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, you gave them a one-way.
Who has the bomb?
Matt, you have the bomb!
It's me!
Okay, we got it.
I killed him.
360.
I was like, where did the bomb go?
Okay, let me lower the screen a little bit.
What the frick?
Don't frickin' silence me.
I'm not silencing just you.
My voice will be heard.
Okay.
I DM'd them.
We are in VC.
It's gonna be just us three.
We're gonna have to 3v5.
Well, technically 4v5.
We do have a sub.
Who's our sub?
One of the community members who's been playing Shinova for like a while now.
Wait, put him in.
Did you just wake up?
Yeah.
Okay.
They're rezzing!
Finish him!
They're behind a frickin' wall!
Then walk up!
I have the bomb.
I am!
Oh my god.
I'm frickin' rezzing you.
Noob down.
Yeah, it's been taken out.
I'm planning.
I'm planning this corner.
We're doing it.
You should've got a katana if you're playing sniper.
Katana?
Yeah, you can.
Instead of a pistol, you get a katana.
Why the frick would I get a katana as a sniper rifle?
Because when they push you, you can bring up the frickin' sword and be like, I have the enemy on my side.
Okay, so what if they're mid-range?
Then shoot them with your sniper.
Yo, I'm taking out the frickin' Uzi, bro.
Oh, you got the Uzi, bro?
You got the Uzi?
I got the frickin' Deagle.
I got the Uzi.
The shotgun might not be real, I don't know.
That looks more like a Deag.
Wait, Nex, have you downloaded the game yet?
I don't know.
Yeah, yeah, I did that yesterday.
Alright, alright.
I just had to.
Boom, headshot.
Let's go.
I have no idea where is a good place.
Okay, I'm planting.
If I die, it's your fault.
Denied.
Okay, I planted.
What is this bubble?
Where are you?
There you go.
Boom, headshot.
Where?
Victory.
Yes, we did it.
You know what?
They're gonna not even go...
They're not even gonna fucking walk towards you.
That guy has TTV in his name.
He has 6 damage.
Are you really?
Bro.
That's fucked.
He's ready to go in his chat and just be like, SLAM!
Bro, he's gonna get banned on Twitch.
Is that bannable now?
Bullying is bannable, yeah.
Just go in there and be like, you did really good.
And then give a smile.
I'll say, my name is Deez.
My audio...
Wait.
Sound guy, I...
Sound guy, I lowered the discord.
This guy is getting solo killed by the turret.
Oh, he finally stopped.
Tyler, please.
Tyler.
I have to use my heals on you.
Alright.
TTV are down.
Oh my god.
That's all you needed.
I have a dirty flank.
I've arrived.
I'm rezzing.
I'm okay.
I killed one.
I need to reload.
Nice!
We did it!
We literally won one more game.
Healing grenade out.
Wait, I can't...
I can't pick the guy I just played on defense.
Fuck.
He's a one-sider.
That's just how it is.
What does the interceptor do?
I don't know.
I think it gets rid of other people's utility.
Because it's interceptor.
I'm going to sit in the corner with a shotgun.
That's all I can think about what it does.
Guys, look.
I'm top gun.
Alright, sound guy.
Lowered it a bit.
More again.
Yeah, I have a guy that helps me deal with sound balancing.
Because I can't do it myself.
He's just sound guy?
That's fucked up.
That's his name!
I didn't even give him a nickname.
Like CG or some shit.
CG?
Yeah, sound guy.
The whole point is that...
Did you spell sound with a C?
Yeah.
For real?
I don't think that's how it's spelled.
Hey, words can be whatever I want them to be.
Because words are a social construct and changing all the time.
Then why are you...
Why can't we call you...
Why is it not C-U-R-E?
Or why is it spelled with an S?
Why is surefour spelled with an S then?
Why is it surefour spelled with a C?
Well, because actually my name was a randomly generated name on Xbox Live.
Yeah, so you're letting...
You're letting an AI decide...
Dictate your name?
Yeah, I'd do it again.
Wow, you're not even gonna...
So you're letting a robot decide for you.
So you have no free will, essentially.
All I'm saying is...
If robots took over and they said...
Listen, you don't have to work anymore.
You're just gonna have to let us take over.
I'd be like, I bet I'm gonna be on Throne and Liberty.
Yeah, same.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah, but how would you make money?
Hey, if they're controlling everything, I don't need to make money.
I'm pretty sure money is still...
Yeah, I'm pretty sure money is still a thing.
MVP!
Jesus Christ.
Alright, but like...
If sex robots were a thing...
Would you let that take over?
Oh, zero.
I didn't even have to hear the end of that.
I just said, yeah.
He's like, yeah, I'm down.
I don't think we can play another game.
I don't think.
So we are missing one more person.
So the sub might have to come in here if...
If that other person's not here.
I'm on my...
I'm on my kill ranking grind in Throne and Liberty.
Oh shit, is it fun?
Is that the one from Amazon?
Yeah, it's very fun.
Our guild is a four man alliance.
And we're just running the server.
We're on Benediction.
Okay, I'm on...
I'm on Amos.
Was that free to play or early access?
Early access one.
We were at early access at the start.
But then someone had to like, not play for a bit.
So then we switched to free to play servers.
For a fresh start.
Yeah.
Wait, apparently...
Aztec is currently playing a different game.
Why is he playing?
Is he playing Destiny?
Wait, oh no, he's playing Descendant.
The first Descendant.
Does he remember?
That game is more of like, the ass Descendant.
Damn.
Bunny got a sick one.
Someone's like, leaks your force friend code.
I already did.
You gotta wait until the VOD's over.
Who's fucking leaking my friend code?
I don't think he's gonna like, come back to Trenova after this.
I think he's gonna stick with Deadlock.
Why the fuck would you say that?
Prove me wrong then.
Prove me wrong.
Prove Dee's wrong.
Exactly, you're not even gonna prove me wrong.
I'm on the Throne of Liberty grind.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm launching Throne of Liberty real quick.
Alright.
Wait, I can see...
Alright guys, you guys wanna see Shur4's friend code?
Guys, all I'm saying is that everything has a price.
That's not true.
Everything has a price.
How do we...
Okay, you can now...
The players can now...
It'll be our turn.
I'll provide the room code and passcode later.
Wait, where are they at?
Are you a spendy, Abarely?
What does that even mean?
Oh, he's AFK.
You can semi pay to win in Throne of Liberty.
Oh, also by the way...
The team...
The team we're playing against is currently...
Getting it's 7-1 right now.
So, they're not...
They're not having a good time.
Cause like the...
You remember the Yuki Aim team?
That team won the finals.
I'm pretty sure.
I think that team won the championship.
On that first tournament.
Not surprising.
Yeah, we're about to put them in a blender though.
This is about to be too free.
Alright.
We got this.
I believe in us.
It can't be that bad.
Lyrics in the Yuki Aim team.
Oh, this is too free.
Speak your truth, Meg.
What do you mean which one?
There's literally one lyric.
There's a lot of lyrics.
Wait, there's a lot of lyrics?
There's variety guy lyrics?
Lyric, there's listic, there's lyric.
There's lyric that used to be an Apex streamer.
Oh, that lyric.
Yeah.
Is he still free or what?
It's not as free, but it's still kind of free.
I put my Throne of Liberty character in the general chat.
Wait, what build are you?
Longbow Dagger.
What?
What's wrong with that?
Wait, a 3.2k on a free-to-play server?
Yeah.
I wonder how that happened.
Oh, you see that ring over there?
That's a ring of universal power.
Oh, I sold one of those.
I sold mine for 25k.
I sold mine for like 18k, I think.
Nice.
Wait, did you swipe?
Of course!
I was gonna say, 3200?
That's crazy.
The other people buy watches, cars, and other things, and expensive clothing.
Me, someone who lives in their house all the time, I buy items and games to flex and shit on other people in PvP.
Understandable.
I'm at like 2950, but I'm Sword and Shield Wand.
Ah, little healer boy.
Oh, you never die?
Yeah, exactly.
I was a Mercy main in Overwatch.
You were a Mercy main?!
How the fuck did you become an Apex pro being a Mercy main in Overwatch?
I was thinking that too!
I was like, how do you go from Mercy main to fucking Apex pro?
Dude, I was just good at it.
I don't know.
I played the others in Overwatch.
There was like two seasons, I one-tricked Mercy, and then went on.
I came out, I played Ana.
You one-trick!
Not even at Mercy main, you were a one-trick!
Every Mercy player is a one-trick, what do you mean?
Yeah, man!
If you hear anyone ever say, yeah, I play Mercy, you know that's the only person they pick.
Yeah!
100% I did not know...
Okay, of everybody, I'd say I would not expect an act to be a fucking Mercy main.
Yeah, I get that reaction a lot.
They're like, what?
Wait, why did you play the other support?
What was it about Mercy that just made you one-of-one-trick?
He's a heal slut, bro.
I got immense satisfaction out of hiding like a bitch while my whole team died and then flying out and rezzing everybody.
You're a dad!
Oh my god, you're the die-on point!
I have rezzed!
Literally.
I was like, die-on point, don't blow ults, just get their ults and then we reheat.
I'm just hiding in a corner.
He was that Mercy.
Literally hiding in the King's Row bathroom.
That shit worked, though.
It did.
It was great.
It did, and the Zarya saves the grab for it.
So the Zarya would grab and then you would Mercy Rez.
Oh, that's true, that's true.
Sometimes you'd be ratting and you'd find the enemy team's Mercy also ratting in a corner and you'd have a little fucking pistol off.
Blasting each other with the blickies.
That shit was awesome.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
I don't think Aztec is coming.
He's doing a sponsored stream for the First Descendant.
A sponsored stream during the tournament.
Alright, bring the community member in.
Tag him in.
I think he accidentally overscheduled.
It's alright.
It's okay.
As long as we four know what we're doing.
Bro, my game is still patching.
You're still patching?
Wait, you've been patching this entire time?
Yeah, literally.
I can't even get in the game.
Wait, what percentage are you at?
85 and it's been on death for like 10 minutes.
What?
Alright, grab another community member in.
Wait,
next, what are you gonna play?
The shard girl again, probably.
Yeah, that's what he played last time.
Okay, you gotta stop pushing up though.
The only person Wildfrag was sure for, okay?
Shush.
I was MVP.
You were MVP.
Yeah, yeah, he was MVP.
You gotta remember, you're playing against people who are NA next.
You gotta remember your ping.
You gotta remember your ping with the shard girl.
The shard girl is like, frag.
I think Aztec is streaming right now, but he has another sponsored stream right now.
Yeah, I don't know if he's... like, we added him, but...
The radio is silent from him, so we don't know.
Yeah, so, I mean, and we see him streaming at the moment, so...
But I think he has to do a sponsored stream, so I don't know.
Alright.
Yeah, alright.
You guys have fun.
Thank you.
He's gone.
Only an MMO could make me fix my... well, semi-fix my sleep schedule.
How?
What?
Shouldn't that ruin it?
Well, so, there's a bunch of, like, scheduling things and throwing away your night.
And World Bosses spawn at 12 at my time, and I normally wake up at, like, 3 PM.
Wait, so what time do you sleep right now?
I usually went to bed at 7 AM every day, but now I've been going to bed at, like, 3 or 4 AM.
And waking up at 11.30.
Oh!
Or you go to bed when they do maintenance.
Yeah, fucking...
They'll just be like, maintenance will begin in 2 hours.
Game will be online for 8 hours.
I'm just like, damn!
I would finish streaming and be like, yeah, thrown in liberty time.
Maintenance in 2 hours.
I'm like, what the fuck?!
That's what you get for locking it.
That's what you get.
This is fucking bullshit.
Shouldn't have locked you hard.
I'm locking my shit.
I got locks on my dick, bro.
Alright, codes up.
Codes up.
I'm gonna hide my screen just in case.
Dude, I can see whatever I want because you're an indie now.
That's true.
But no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, wait, wait.
What's your problem?
Why was that an instant 80?
Why'd you backpedal like that?
Wait, because...
Huh?
Because there's some things I know you want to say and I cannot.
Like what?
I'm not going to be specific here.
That's not true because I could still get cancelled.
No, you can't.
I don't say anything that cancels you.
What?
I'm going to sue for, what's the word, defamation.
Defamation?
Yeah, this is defamation right now.
Alright, do it.
Do it right now.
Get that lawyer in.
I'll get that freaking lawyer.
Yeah?
Yeah.
No boss, you would never sue me.
I would be able to just join this lobby without putting a password.
Are they sure they have a password?
Oh yeah, you should have said that out loud.
No, but none of us showed the code anyway.
Yeah, I didn't show it.
Yeah, I definitely didn't show the code.
It sure is a good thing that no one showed the code.
Yo, what's up Aqua?
How's it going?
Oh, hi.
Hello.
Wait, someone's right.
Can't sue for defamation.
There's nothing to defame.
That's right.
You were defaming me.
You were saying I could get you banned.
No, I said cancelled.
I said you could get me cancelled.
Yeah, that's defamation.
That's not defamation.
It depends on what you say.
Exactly, but you're leaving it open.
And everyone's imaginations are wandering to the worst things.
That's not even defamation.
VTubers aren't real.
You're right.
How do you sue a VTuber?
We're not even real.
I hire a hacker.
You hire and delete the program.
Delete the PNG off the internet.
Yeah.
Okay, so how are we playing?
Okay, so next you're playing the shark.
Aqua, what are you playing?
I just fill whatever you guys don't want to play.
Okay, cool.
I like the Symmetra girl.
I know he likes the Symmetra girl.
Yeah, but that's the character only I know how to play.
I'm the only one that responded to it.
No, yeah, I know.
Oh, yeah, you are.
You're very... See, you're so social, Surefour.
I'm a good teammate.
You're a good person.
I didn't respond to it.
I'm sorry.
I got ghosted.
Yeah, okay, I apologize.
Our other teammates didn't apologize.
They're trying to pretend nothing happened.
Oh, I was sleeping.
I got added to the Discord late.
You got added?
You got added, but like posted that after you got added.
So you should have seen it.
I can literally look at timestamps.
It literally shows you.
Okay, I'm looking at general.
You got added at 12.01pm yesterday.
And they posted that clip at like... where is it?
I don't know.
You didn't see it either.
You don't even know where it is.
They deleted it.
They posted that at 9.48pm.
No, they didn't.
Okay, it's there somewhere.
It's around that time because they posted two gifs.
Oh, it's 7.31pm because Surefour replied SimGaming.
Okay, there you go.
7.09pm.
And you were added seven hours before he posted that clip.
No, I wasn't.
I literally can see in the general.
The best part about that clip is that we still lost the game.
Oh, that's not gonna happen to us, right?
Yeah, yeah.
Surely not.
That's not gonna happen to us.
We're sweeping today.
Awesome.
Oh, yeah.
We don't lose.
We don't do that.
Okay, so next.
How's it going with your thing?
Now, it's verifying, but it's going faster.
It's on 25%.
Okay, holy shit.
It's on 25%?
Now, 50.
Okay, this one is faster.
Okay, okay.
I was gonna be like, there's a lot.
That's a lot of percentage.
I know.
It's at 69 now.
Next, why didn't you patch this before you went to bed?
I didn't think there would be a huge-ass fucking patch.
What do you mean?
I downloaded the game a day ago and I was like, okay, that's good enough, right?
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
I believe in us.
It's fine.
I don't need to do this.
Okay, um...
What do you guys want to play?
Wait, they're still in another game.
They're still playing another- wait, why are we here?
We could have just played our game.
We could play one game, like, by ourselves.
Wait, can we still do that now?
I mean, we could.
I mean, they're literally- it's like 0-2, so we could literally do a game.
Are we gonna be- Alright, are you guys- Are we gonna be bad boys?
Let's do it.
Okay, I'm done.
Alright, let's do it.
If anything, if you're gonna blame anybody, we'll just say the community member who told us to.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait...
That's good, right?
Yeah, alright.
No, no, no, no, no.
I don't know about that one.
Do it for the team!
As the designated substitute, you gotta- No, you're the- you're the team captain, I think you should do it for me.
Yes, and as the team captain, I can delegate.
Is this dude still patching?
Yeah, he is.
I am getting on a right meow.
Oh,
wait, did they finish?
Oh, they did.
Okay, thank God.
Guys, thank God we didn't.
Yeah, we didn't leave.
Thank God I stopped this in time.
Chat?
Oh my God, thank God.
I'm gonna get some Coke, bro.
All right.
I'm just waiting for our...
the other team to come in.
All right.
We're still waiting for it.
You're booting it up right now, right?
Next?
Yeah, yeah.
How do I get in?
Um, they give us a code in our team, uh, custom teammate.
Search to room code.
Got it.
All right, we're in.
Is your sense okay?
Did you configure your settings?
Yeah, I did that.
Okay, thank God.
All right.
I just had to be sure.
Not everything, but maybe like...
Just had to be sure.
All right.
Should we... Are we all ready to go?
Oh, y'all be not tipping the morning to you.
All right, we're all ready, right?
No.
Okay.
I am.
All right, we're all mostly ready.
My no is alive, by the way.
All right, I am.
I'll press R.
Wait, room.
R.
Universal.
Universal ready up.
Level 64?
Who's level 64?
Oh, shit.
I think she... She's a grinder.
I know, I think she just got like extra XP cards.
Oh, that's gonna be like... We all got that.
Yeah, but we didn't.
We didn't use it.
She got like more than us, I think.
Wait, how?
Why the hell did she get XP?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Where's my co-attack?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm sponsored.
Where's my XP?
Wait, what?
What are you gonna say?
You know, like...
What?
Mernie.
Oh, true.
I don't need those.
Yeah, you're right.
I don't need XP cards.
You're right.
You can buy the XP cards.
Yeah, why are you complaining?
Uh, because complaining is fun sometimes.
Yeah, I don't need the XP cards.
I got... I got more than enough.
Wait, do we need um...
Don't we uh...
What the fuck?
What is this world chat shit going on?
I just minimized it.
There's wild shit in there.
That's... Yeah, there's wild shit.
I just minimized it, you know.
Okay, so...
Those are the people you have to worry about canceling you.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, how do you minimize it?
The little button right beside it.
Oh, there it is!
Okay, guys, just so you guys know, if you see something really fucked up in the world chat, it was... I was very unaware.
So, I'm sorry.
I was very unaware.
Well, do you have to ready up, Mac?
Oh, do I?
It'd be funny if we start the game after that.
I don't know.
Are they just introducing us?
Maybe.
Introduce Deez.
Nah.
There it is.
Next, what's 25?
Oh, yeah, we're doing Windytown.
We're doing that.
He's nuts in your mouth.
Fuck you.
Got him.
I don't want to play anymore.
Look what you did, Jerm4.
We lost.
Team Cohesion up.
Chemistry up.
Oh my god.
We're...
Are they actually introducing us, guys?
I don't want to pull up the stream because I don't want to seem like I'm stream sniping.
Because we managed to convince them not to put a three minute delay.
So, we gotta do that.
I don't know.
I think you were like, do we have to?
I just went, wait, we gotta do this?
Yeah, and then they're like, never.
No, you don't.
Yeah, because originally, wait, we missed.
Wait, what happened to next?
Uh, my disconnected.
Wait, how did you disconnect?
My internet is very good.
Oh, no.
Are we next?
Are we truly, truly, do we know what happened?
Are we gonna need another sub?
Yeah, we're gonna need another substitute next?
What's going on here?
Gotta be truthful next.
Nah, I'll be fine.
My cable is just fucked.
I need to buy a new one.
I'll be fine.
He lies.
He lies naturally.
It's not like you guys could find a fucking person to come in at this point.
Oh, you won't.
Yeah, you want to bet, son?
You want to bet?
We will fucking add the discord.
Yeah, you're replaceable.
We're like team cohesion, guys, right?
True.
We would lose that.
Yeah, we would, but we can rebuild it.
We can remake it.
Oh, come on.
I just have to ask a new person.
Yes, yeah, that's it.
That's all you have to do.
That's toxic doki.
Surefour started it!
Why am I getting blamed?
I'm a bully.
I'm just an enabler.
True.
That's different.
I'm just enabling surefour to continue.
I would be doing it anyways.
The vibes, we're raising up the vibes already.
I like how mac is staying quiet because he doesn't want to be the next target.
I'm just existing, man.
He's probably got throne of liberty on his second monitor.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
What?
I mean we can look at it on steam.
Yeah.
I'm looking on steam.
Wait, do I even have you on steam?
Mac, I don't even know.
I don't think you do.
You could be appearing offline.
That's true.
I see so many other people on throne and liberty right now.
I would be on it.
It's a good game.
It's a great game.
I can't get into MOBAs or MMOs.
Sorry, MMOs.
Sorry, they're both starts with M.
Better in life than having an MMO you can grind.
Yeah, I can never get into it.
I've tried a lot of MMOs and none of them have gotten me interested, but throne of liberty I actually like.
Wait, what's up with throne and liberty that was different?
PvP.
That's really it.
I like killing people.
Ah, in game.
Yeah.
Yeah, where else would it be?
It's great, especially before.
Oh, you can go.
Sorry.
Especially when you pull up with like your whole guild to like a world boss and then there's another.
Oh, yeah.
And then you just have a war.
Oh, you can fight another another team like another guild while you're doing it.
Some some world bosses are in conflict.
So the entire area is just PvP on so it's it can be like 200 people.
That's crazy.
Yeah, dungeons will have it happen too like dungeons some of them will like Their doors will close at nighttime, but yeah inside the dungeon when the door closes and it's nighttime, it becomes a conflict zone So it's just a free for all for everyone that's locked in And then if you kill everyone the dungeon's yours,
yeah, you just get the freest loot.
It's it's actually just Oh, that sounds interesting That was my last my last uh Open world event I did
Yeah, the only thing I don't like is needing to like defend boonstones and shit like that I think that stuff's annoying.
That's fun Why is it fun?
I mean my my guild when when we went to do it It was we just got slaughtered because the guy that was leading it was Why did you have him as the leader then?
Our our guild is the slaughterers so it's fun The way the boonstones work is you a boonstone gives you a boon obviously for the when you have it, but people can Say they're gonna challenge it for the right to fight for it.
Yeah, and it's basically like that guilt 70 versus 70 for like 14 minutes And whoever wins and holds in that 14 minutes gets the boonstone Oh, so you just gotta protect the territory.
Yeah, it's basically a ctf Oh capture.
Oh I see well, it's more it's more king of the hilly because it's like there's one there's a flag in the middle and then like everyone's basically Fighting on this like pillar.
That's like Got the flag on it Oh shit Sounds are different the one that dude the one that I did Like I don't know if you fought at it before it's literally just a vertical pillar in the middle of the desert with like Grapples in the stairway.
That's the one we had that's the one that we tried to attack bro.
That was the worst experience i've ever Maybe it was sure force guild you attack Oh, yeah difference zero oh man, if only it was that'd be fucking hilarious Oh my god Oh my god, oh my I thought we were never gonna start not gonna lie I forgot his name,
but i'm gonna play the guy that looks like dante on the tag.
Okay, i'm playing You play the healer, okay.
Yeah No, no, he's attacked.
Yeah.
Yeah, i'll play i'll play ming then Wait, what names do we got again?
Um, you guys can go with I got smoke grenade healing.
I have frag and wind.
Yeah next Next you should use smoke grenades because your character can scan through walls I can scan uh doki you should use uh interceptor instead of wind grenade probably interceptor.
Okay.
Yeah Am I good at smokes or should I use To go through my queue.
No, I think I think smokes are fine All right I never used interceptor.
So let's let's fucking do it Yeah, you can just throw it straight at your feet if like you're in like a corner or something.
Okay, they'll try to nade you out Oh my god, it's finally happening.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's a trophy system basically.
Okay, it's finally happening.
They're spelling my name wrong All right guys, it's finally happening All right, where are we going?
I'll grab it.
No, they're spelling it s-u-r-f-o-r-e.
Where do you guys want to go?
I'll just i'll just follow you guys All right, you're the one who knows stuff
Let's go let's go let's go be long and then we got two sniper rifles You wall from like here and then wall like to here like from here to here Yeah, I cut the site in half.
Yeah, I cut the site.
Yeah, and we're gonna we're gonna plant on on this thing All right Yeah So just come here come to this corner And put your wall.
Yep.
I'm surprised I didn't have anyone peeking long.
I'm throwing an interceptor down Someone should probably take control of the height above me here.
Yeah.
I'll i'll come up there to save the There's a bear on point We can you can try to plant I'm planning but i'm literally I don't know where I am.
Can I plant it?
And then just just run this way Okay
All right, i'm never planting again after that
One more uh on my ping on my ping here on I can I can see bomb for me.
Yeah She's behind the boxes behind boxes We can just play for the bomb.
Wait, I got a healing aid for you I think they smoked it.
They smoked it.
W support.
Throw an aid on it.
Yeah, i'm queuing i'm gonna I killed another
That's that's one now we keep doing it over and over again until it doesn't work Okay Okay guys, I don't know if I want to do the bomb that was not fun
We can do a different wall we can do this wall and then plant from here to here, okay
We'll take the left side doki we'll plant here wait, no, I don't have the bomb Or no, whoever has the bomb whoever has the mom will plant there and then we'll cover the left side for them And if they go Sniper over there sniper over there.
You can win this 1v1.
I believe in you Well, I was just scanning for you guys, so, you know I'm splitting the site On me on me right here.
You can get it left.
You can get it.
Yeah.
Yeah, get on the left Get on the left and try to plant.
She's low.
She's low up top Okay, i'm i'm gonna i'll cover i'll cover your left I needed the right side of the wall.
There's there's people on my um, you're getting bared It's to my right People here.
I'm shooting the bear.
Nice.
We can we can leave again.
We can leave again.
We can just play off site They're on they're they're on one for 110 Yep Um, i'm gonna name the event i'm gonna try to kill her.
Oh, yeah Someone's pushing it up Someone's on
All right My name's d you know what thank god we had this sub
I don't think any of us will go to IGL, that's for sure.
I'm not an IGL-er.
Well, I can IGL when I play the game a lot, and I'm 14.
Yeah, but you hate IGL.
None of us play the game a lot, so we got Aqua here, he's got like default setup and shit.
You can have a bunch of lemmings that can aim, so you listen to me.
I'm playing an RTS, and you guys are my lemmings.
Yeah, yeah.
Man down!
Okay, okay.
I can rez.
Just cover us.
Um, Fuchsia's low.
And I can heal.
I got one.
Oh, we can use that as a stun.
Get the bomb!
Yeah, just put the wall down.
I'm gonna do the left wall again.
I got one.
Yep.
I'm doing right wall, actually.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
You can plant shallow here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got you.
I got heal for you.
Plant shallow.
Plant shallow next on the right.
It's fine.
Oh, they painted.
They painted on this.
Okay, okay.
Let's go off set again.
They probably ulted.
They're bombing.
They're defusing.
They're on bomb.
Yeah.
I think they stopped.
Oh, fuck!
There's a guy right here.
Nice, nice, nice.
There's a sniper over here on me.
Dude, why is that hitting?
They're defusing.
Nice.
I killed the sniper.
They're using the bear as cover again.
They have not a fucking...
They fucking tried to defuse three times.
Yippee!
That guy was defusing behind the bear.
He was just like...
No!
He just used the bear as cover.
That's an actual shot.
Holy shit!
And then we got there again!
Let's do it!
Let's keep doing it!
One more time!
Like, what's stopping us?
Let's just do it again.
They can't stop us.
Literally nothing.
Exactly.
If it works, it works.
Yeah.
I'm scanning the high ground.
Let's go!
I'm just a heal bot.
Now it's my turn.
Yeah, they really don't want to shoot through my wall.
They're scared.
This is great.
This is working.
Okay, there's one.
Two up top!
They're holding their own.
They're trying.
We have to fight for this now.
We have to fight for the space.
Guys, maybe we shouldn't have done this again.
Does this guy know he's scanned, though?
I don't think so.
I don't think they do.
I got wanted.
Bear?
Nair?
I smoked that high peek.
I'm looking at...
I got a healing nade for you.
I got two.
Yeah, I got a healing.
You're getting healed.
Can you just hold this angle?
Did we plan already or no?
Oh, wait!
Our push is done.
I can't go over there.
Yeah, I can try to pick up bomb.
Yeah, I walled the left side if you want to go for the plant.
It's my ult wall, so you can't get shot.
I got two.
Nice, nice.
I'm healing you.
I almost got an ace.
I was going for the ace, bro.
It's fine.
It happens.
We still got it.
Okay, maybe we should go A now.
Do you really want to give them a point?
Wait, wait, wait.
Are you trying to 9-0 with that?
No, I messed with that.
I fucked with that.
Yeah, yeah.
We're here to send a message.
It's about sending a message.
Yeah, exactly.
We can keep going B and just go 9-0.
And then we feel good about ourselves.
Yeah, it goes to 9.
When we fight, you key aim.
That's when we can, you know, that's when we can get karma.
Yeah, that's when we get 9-0ed.
Yeah.
Bottom bridge.
Yep.
Sniper 50.
Eyes dead.
We can put the wall up.
Okay.
I'm coming.
I healed you.
I'm not looking at the right side, so I'm going to look.
Right now.
I don't see nobody.
Unless you want to.
You can look at it.
Got you, I healed you.
He's in spawn.
Oh, he is?
I'm hunting him.
Alright, let's go.
He ran.
Let's go.
I found him.
He's right there.
You got this.
Yeah!
Yippee!
Let's go!
How many more rounds are we just...
We just keep doing it.
Until it doesn't work.
Yeah, until it doesn't work.
No, I meant like, when do we switch sides?
Oh, six.
Wait, I haven't done a rank in a while.
How many points is switching...
Press the control thing and then you can see.
The control thing?
The control?
You mean tab?
Tab?
Oh, three more rounds.
Three more rounds.
Okay.
The control thing.
Dude, all you've done is die, you freaking noob.
Nah, I got the most damage.
Look at that shit, okay?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, 73 synergy.
Yeah, yeah.
He's been planting.
I fucked up my sonar.
Here you go, I got you.
I got a heal for you.
I gave you two of my heals.
I got the sniper.
Nice, I'm pushing up.
I'm nading the Noct.
I'm gonna try to...
Yeah, I'm gonna try to thirst the Noct if your nade doesn't hit.
I'm gonna...
Oh, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, we can try to get the wall down.
I gave you another heal so you can go and keep planting.
Just keep planting.
There's a guy to the right side, yeah?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, to the left side, too.
Oh, they pushed the left.
They were ready this time.
Yeah.
I'm so bad.
Through your wall.
Through the wall.
Oh, wait.
No, there was one right there.
They weren't getting scanned.
Wait, I'm res-able.
Where are you?
I can't see anything.
I'm up top.
I'm so confused with this area.
There's only one left.
Only one left.
Where is he?
On me, Ducky.
Oh, he is?
Oh, okay.
Oh, he's...
He's on you?
Thank you.
He's on himself?
Yeah, I got him.
I got him.
Wait, you didn't even pick me up!
Oh, wait, no.
No, of course not.
Hey, guys.
I max-traded.
Nice.
I haven't even had an opportunity to use my ult.
Me, too.
Let's go in.
Let's go plant.
I don't want to die.
It's okay.
That's why I'm here.
I heal you through this plant.
True, true.
Exactly.
Yeah, yeah.
I heal you through the plant so you can live.
That's your life right now.
Dude, what a fucked up game.
Wait, no.
Your ult is revive, right?
So you should ult and then go plant.
Mine?
I don't think so.
Mine is like...
Isn't it?
What is my ult?
I don't...
I'm pretty sure.
Isn't it?
One's bridge.
Yeah, it can ult while he plants.
Yeah.
One for them.
Are you kidding me?
Oh.
There's a person here on this side.
Oh, I almost got sniped.
He's to the right.
He left already.
Okay.
Alright, ult and plant next.
Ult and plant.
That's the strat.
Oh, I got...
I got bombed.
Oh my...
Okay.
Let me ult for you.
Thank you.
Oh, I got you.
Oh, the left.
The left.
They're pushing.
Oh, they're pushing.
I got...
I traded.
Oh, it's winnable next.
This is it.
This is your character arc.
Bye.
That was in your character arc.
Wait.
We couldn't get the 9-0 after all.
That's alright.
We go A now.
Now we go A.
Now we...
No, no, no.
They're going to expect us to go a different site because we lost.
So we just go again.
That's true.
That's so true.
Alright.
We figured it out.
Okay.
And then after...
After that, then we go A.
No, no, no.
Because then they're surely going to believe that we go A.
So we just go B again.
We never couldn't experience A?
Is that...
Is that it?
I only want to experience a site while defending it.
I want to know what A looks like in a competitive sense.
Guys, they're set up.
Guys, I think they know we were going to go B, guys.
Hey, we could late rotate.
You want to do it?
Me and Nex are getting a little active.
Okay.
And then we're pushing up.
We can go back.
Alright.
Bye.
Let's go.
Bye-bye.
Let's go A.
I'll wait for you guys.
You guys want to go through mid or go full rotation?
What do you think, IGL?
I think going through A mid is fine.
I'm just going to throw an interceptor down, then we'll just run through it.
Can you smoke this?
Can you smoke my ping here?
I cannot right now.
One sec, one sec.
I'm taking high ground A side.
I got one.
That's one.
Nice.
I'll just run through.
Run through the window and then go to site.
I got scan in a second.
Abe, you can probably start lurking up through B.
I'm going to take high ground here.
There's still one guy that's holding A.
No one in spawn right now.
Oh, I see.
Oh my god.
I don't know where people are.
They're all there.
Holy shit, they're all there.
You guys okay?
He has backshots.
Wait, there's one on site.
Wait, who's giving backshots?
Ow, to the left.
Abe is giving backshots.
I got him.
I got the guy on site.
I got him on site.
I got him too.
He's 1 HP.
I got your trade.
Nice, let's go.
Okay, now we go back to B, right?
No, now we go B again.
Oh, wait, we're defending.
We can't do it anymore.
Now we go B on defense.
Okay, whatever you guys want me to.
Okay, wait.
You want me to play Celestia or I can play Maddalena?
Whatever you think we need the most.
I'm playing Sniper.
He's just going to be on Sniper.
Yeah, I'll play Celestia.
I'm going B.
I'm going to play the bear.
You never even played the bear before.
Yeah, I've been experimenting.
What happened to those three hours?
What?
Look, man.
I just decided that Aubrey just had to win.
It's just that simple.
All the women.
Alright, I'll go A then.
I'll be the sole A defender.
Oh my god, I'm a calico cat.
Oh my god, Neko.
Alright.
Guys, what if they all rush A?
What do I do?
You hold the line until backup comes.
What if I die for it?
Well, that's fucking war, isn't it?
I'd die for the country.
You'd die for your country and your cause.
Will you remember me?
They're going mid.
Oh my god.
They're cheating, they're hacking.
Wait, wait, wait.
There's one.
It's stupid.
Hacker reporting hacker man.
Report, report.
But he's playing the same character as you.
Oh god.
Wait, they're mid, they're mid, they're mid.
There's one B.
They're looking at me.
There's one B, man.
Oh shit, I got sniped, I got sniped.
Two B, two B.
I'll try to help you B.
I downed one.
Meredith's dead.
Ming behind you, Ming behind you.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh my god.
I'm doing a win.
I'm win-grenading up there.
On me, on me.
I'm killing the guy in the win-grenade.
One's going to A.
I killed him.
There's one left.
I got one, I got him, I got him, I got him.
Let's go.
You know what?
I think I'm fine with Aztek not being on our team.
Dude, that's fucked up.
Wait, wait.
Why is bottom frag saying something like that, bro?
You're one in five.
You have five deaths.
You almost have the entire team combined deaths.
Look at my synergy though.
What the fuck does synergy even mean?
I don't know.
Well, I'm obviously the most skilled in the lobby.
That's shown by Tab, with skill.
51.
There's nothing B.
Oh my god, I don't see anyone A yet.
I'm rotating, I'm rotating.
Wait, wait, wait.
I think they're mid, I think they're mid.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, I can double jump on this character?
Can I jump shot?
They all can double jump.
I see them, I see them.
They're over here.
Yeah, there's two mid.
I'm just sitting invisible on top of site.
A lot of mid, a lot of mid.
There's so many mid.
Please help me.
We're right here.
We're literally right here.
Wait, no, don't rotate off.
Wait, wait, wait, they're here.
They're on me, they're on me, they're on me.
Wait, wait, wait, there's one on B, there's one on B.
We can kill this one.
I hit one for 89.
They're on my turret, they're on my turret.
I can't do anything.
They're planting.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll fight this guy, I'll fight this guy.
They're low, they're low, they're low.
Planting is low.
Help me.
I got two.
Oh my god.
They're pushing.
Help me.
I got one, I got one.
There's only one left.
I'm coming over.
I need uppies, I need uppies.
I'm literally heading over to you.
I swear to god.
You let me die.
What are you doing?
What are you doing for me?
I was getting to cover.
We did it, guys.
We did it.
Look at that now.
Who's the fucking bottom?
Actually, I am.
You are still bottom frag.
You just have more synergy points.
You literally...
I am better.
The only reason why you're not bottom frag is because you are bottom frag.
You just have more synergy.
Shh, shh, shh.
They want to ban you.
That's all we have.
That's our sub!
They can bring their sub in.
They can literally bring in their sub.
Just play with their sub.
Is it best of three?
Yeah, so we do one more map and we win this.
This is the last map.
I thought it was best of one.
No, it's...
Best of one and a best of three.
No.
No, that doesn't make sense.
What the fuck?
Please.
This is our IGL.
You can't ban the IGL.
The sub is the IGL.
I don't know if that should be a thing.
This is fun.
Our sub even has the most ping.
That's a lie.
Nex has the most ping.
But like...
Our sub has the second most ping.
He's already debuffed as hell.
I'm just a tactical shooter.
Ping matters.
I'm gonna increase my oath.
Increase your oath?
What does that even mean?
Wait, Blurr is asking you to swap positions with me.
Should I say yes?
Swap what?
Like team position?
Wait, what do you mean?
Team A to Team B.
Yeah, yeah.
You wanna leave us like that?
No.
He wants to swap Team A to Team B.
Wait, why?
What does that even do?
There's no...
There's no reason for this.
It's just some fucking mind game.
You say no.
No.
Bro, I'm giving my girl some gifts right now.
Oh, are you?
Oh yeah, by the way guys.
We have an oath here.
So you can give her like...
Like gifts to make her love you more.
I assume.
Fuck.
Love me now.
What did you give her?
I'm giving her gifts.
What did I give her?
I don't even know what I gave her.
Oh, I upgraded my oath level.
I gave her...
Soon we can have sex.
Wait, you haven't even held her hand yet.
The force of gravity.
Oath level 2.
You haven't even held her hand yet.
I'm about to goon.
The top one of the archer level, bro.
I haven't played that in like 3 months.
Wait, next can put her on.
We need to increase our affinity.
Wait, we have to move to team B for...
What's it called?
Defense?
Yeah, for defense.
We have intertwined thoughts.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
I gave her a fucking death note?
What the fuck?
Why is Surefour like this?
He's for the people.
I'm the people's champ.
He's the people's champ.
Wait, I don't have gifts yet for her.
Yeah.
Wait, how do you have gifts for her?
Wouldn't you like to fucking know?
What did you... Did you spend money?
Hell fucking no.
How do you have...
I got this shit for free.
She's giving me a gift!
I wanna... I wanna... I wanna love her.
Stickers!
I wanna love her too!
Wait.
Check inventory?
But I have no gifts in my inventory.
Noob.
Down.
Okay, we need...
Next, you gotta swap with Wanted.
Wait, what?
You have to swap.
We're defending.
Wait, we're defending!
That means Surefour's gonna play Sniper on...
Oh, it's over.
This is literally...
I'm gonna play Sniper on both.
That's... You're right.
Yeah, but now you get to play Sniper on both.
I'm gonna play Sniper on defense too.
Defense.
Alright.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I don't know how long it's gonna take.
I'll be right back.
Oh?
What's that sound?
I'm back.
What do you mean?
I heard someone... sounds.
Maybe you're...
Is it your... your girl?
Oh, dude, I wish.
And you wanted to get rid of her.
You wanted to change her.
I do still wanna change her.
I thought you loved her!
I'm a player.
I got multiple 2D bitches on my roster, if you know what I mean.
Yeah?
Where's the proof?
Who would I choose?
Yeah, out of all of these girls.
I would choose Ming.
Ming?
Wait, what does Ming look like?
Oh!
Yeah, I can see you choose her.
I...
Yeah.
Inventory.
Where's my inventory, chat?
Oh, there it is!
Good googly moogly, that Angus juice.
Is it the gift box?
Hmm.
Is the gift that I give her from the gift box?
I wonder.
How was I supposed to know?
Gifts in the gift box?
Sorry, I'm gifting her stuff now.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Oh, I need one more gift and then she'll love me more.
Bro, you had ten of them.
Yeah, but like, I had to, you know, I don't want to use all of them.
You can't just shower her with gifts right away.
You gotta, you know, pace yourself.
Yeah, you can.
It's called love bombing.
Thank you for...
I'm betting you ignored him.
And then it makes them want you more.
Hello?
Exactly.
And how do you guys know so much about me?
Oh, don't worry about it.
Wait.
Wait, I see the dark note.
Wait, I see the death note.
Yeah, why are we giving them a fucking death note though?
I don't know, maybe a notebook design in a collaboration with a fan.
Wait, it isn't.
Wait.
Even the font.
Wait, whoa.
No, no, no.
Dude, look at her fucking mouse.
What is that thing?
That shit looks like a hovercraft.
What mouse?
There's like a part where she's like sitting at her computer and you can see her mouth.
Wait, really?
Yeah, I think you just have to be careful.
Oh, yeah, what the fuck is...
That looks like...
No, that looks like a VR chat.
The VR chat.
Not VR chat.
The VR controller.
Bro, that thing looks like a hoverboard.
I'm poking her head.
Bam!
Wait, no.
Do I have to double tap?
Wait, I think because I'm a higher oath, I get more affectionate.
Is she more affectionate to you now?
Yeah.
What is she doing?
Oh!
Dude, she put her hair behind her ears for me.
Oh my god.
Okay, she doesn't like me.
I poked her.
When I poke her, she puts her hair behind her ears.
That's how you know.
Don't worry.
That's going to be me soon.
You wish.
Oh yeah, I'm level 3 now.
Yeah, well, I'm putting food in the microwave.
When do we start the game?
Wait.
When are we supposed to start?
Guys, this is high level FPS gameplay.
Don't you, like, when you want to take a break, you want to love your waifu a little longer?
See, even my doggo is into that too.
Wait.
Please ignore what I just said.
I blame Surefour.
This is all his fault.
I would never...
If they started the game while I was gone, it wouldn't have mattered.
We got a shark that smells blood in the water.
He's ego pushing the shit out of them.
Who could that be?
What are we waiting for right now?
Like, are they...
We're waiting for these.
These one?
Yeah, these what?
Oh shit.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna look at the mainstream, guys.
The mainstream.
Okay.
I'm using all my XP.
Use.
8 XP cards.
Confirmed.
Why are you using it now?
You're supposed to use it before we go in game.
I don't think...
You don't get XP from customs, right?
I thought it just gave flat XP.
Oh.
Does it?
Yeah, I'm level 59 now.
Oh shit!
Wait, where did I use that?
What the fu...
Wait, I wanna...
I'm gonna use it too.
It's our free stuff.
It's in our store...
Inventory...
And then...
Uh...
EXP card.
Oh, it's a 5k!
I'm using it too.
I don't even know what I got.
What this purple orb stuff is.
It's currency.
Wait, I have another gacha pawn.
What do I have?
What level am I now?
I'm level 60.
I'm still 28.
10.
No, you have to go to...
Career.
Go to career and go to inventory.
And then go...
Click your XP card.
Yeah, I used it and I'm still...
Wait, how am I still...
Sperm?
What?
Sperm, give me a re...
No!
Game, game, game!
You can't even see it!
Yeah!
I got fucking blue balls from my gacha pawn.
Guys, I'm constantly hearing the gacha pawn opening sound now.
That's not good.
Wait, wait, we have a teammate that's AFK.
We didn't know.
Yeah, I'm sure it'll be fine.
Oh yeah, it's gonna be fine.
Yeah, they're back.
He did nothing last game, so it's okay.
Why is it always the bottom?
Why is it always the bottom track?
Yeah, why is it...
Nine seconds, nine seconds!
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Oh my god, wait.
I was...
Go first, go first, go first.
First?
Okay.
I hear constant electric noises.
It won't stop.
Wait, is it my mic?
I was opening the gacha pawn when I got taken to the game.
Oh.
I guess I'm just gonna be electrocuted.
Wait, no, you hear that right now?
Wait, right now?
Okay, wait, that's not good.
That's not good.
Can we just reset?
No, I can deal with it.
Okay, okay.
Sure, if we lose this, we play a third map.
Do we?
Yeah.
Oh, wait, really?
I thought...
Oh, okay.
They said it's two best of ones.
It's just two best of ones.
Oh, okay.
You don't get a...
Yeah.
So what even happens if we lose?
We just get less points.
I think it's a point system.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's a point system.
So we have...
So, yeah.
I'm watching A long.
I'm watching mid.
I'm watching mid as well.
Oh, wait, wait.
They're B long, man.
3B, 3B.
Yeah.
Guys, I'm getting electrocuted.
Oh, careful, Mac.
Careful.
I'm okay.
I'm just...
I'm just getting ice down.
I'm barren.
I'm drowning.
Wait, on the right, on the right.
They're going mid.
I'm rotating.
It's three top mid.
I can't help you there.
I got a turret right there, though.
They're still mid.
Yep.
They're coming back B.
There's people here.
I think I scared them.
There's two.
Yeah.
I'm like a huge fucking plank.
One is still bottom B.
Oh, two top B.
Let me know when they're out.
I'm invising.
Uh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, they're going to kill me.
Oh, I've been spotted.
They're going to come hull.
They're going to come hull probably.
I killed one.
Bomb down B.
Hull, hull, hull, hull, hull.
There's a guy right here.
I can't.
I got one tapped.
There's two in the hallway.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't.
He's low HP on my knock.
It's a sniper.
He's right here.
Yeah, I'm holding top side.
Fucking bad on that, bro.
Shut up.
Huh?
They can't minimize my window.
Bomb's down up top.
They're low.
They're low as fuck.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're low.
Yeah, but...
Surefour's going in.
Oh, we're getting so active.
Surefour's getting so active.
I got bomb.
I can't see.
He's in the smoke, reloading.
There's one left.
He might rez.
No bullets.
Nice!
Oh, yeah!
Let's go!
Bro, I was in the smoke.
I was in the smoke.
Why?
Wait, wait, wait.
He gets top frag for one round.
He gets top frag.
Alright, alright.
Next are other guys on support now.
We put him on support.
You better be on top frag.
All I'm going to say...
All I'm going to say is...
The sniper's pushing.
Not the guy that's pushing.
That's all I'm saying.
That's...
Yeah, I agree.
I agree.
The sniper's really active.
We literally have defense for our sniper.
That's all I'm saying.
And he should not be pushing.
Whoa.
Alright.
We wait.
I'm still being electrocuted.
There's two B now.
Three B.
Four B.
Bro, are they never going A?
Where's my fun?
Then come.
We rotate.
Rotating.
Oh, they naded mid.
Top of mid one.
I'm watching.
Ow.
There's some bottom B.
Did they un-rotate?
No, they're still...
They're mid.
I don't know if they're going to...
They're still mid.
Alright, going back A.
They're rotating to A.
Let's kill the big girl.
Follow me.
Under, under.
There.
Last one right there.
Mid, mid, mid.
We have bomb.
Don't fight them, Doki.
Oh, no.
Oh, I didn't realize they're all there.
One's on their spawn.
On their spawn.
On their spawn?
Oh, okay.
On bomb.
Oh, I'm on my way.
He's right there.
He shot me through the smoke.
One's damaged.
One B, three.
Oh, no.
What the fuck?
That missed.
I'm a loser.
One B, two.
Do I have to win this?
Yes, you got this.
If you win this, if you...
Oh, okay.
I don't think so.
Yeah, I didn't finish the sentence because I could tell.
I should have just gone for a body shot.
Oh, wait.
I know why I lost that.
I don't have armor.
Yeah, same.
Alright.
You can only buy armor in like, dead rounds, right?
I don't know.
Nah, I was two credits short of armor that round.
Now I'm three credits short.
You can sell.
If the undo button is green, you get a full refund.
Next, you're not top frag anymore, Next.
You're not top frag.
They're going B because they know Surefour's on A.
Yeah.
I don't think that's the reason.
Something like that.
No, I'd be scared of them too.
I mean, you literally denied them for last game.
Yeah, it's like a lot of longing for denial.
They're going B again.
Next round, if they win, Surefour, you should go B heaven.
Alright.
There's multiple going upper B.
One bottom B.
I'm leaving A.
Trying to nade them.
One's going to the paper spot B.
There's people in mid too.
They're on next round.
There's two mid.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, we can fight this A.
They might push A.
One's hallway, yeah.
He's in the box.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's low.
They're pushing.
Surefour, they're pushing Surefour.
I'm scared.
I'm trying to head over to you.
I'm going to heal you.
I tried to.
I gave you armor.
Nice shot.
There's people here.
I see them.
I got double peeked.
They're probably going to rez.
I'm rez-able probably.
I'm going to rez.
I smoked.
I win.
So they can't push that.
I'm hurting though.
Oh, they're thirsty.
Yeah.
They're planting.
They're planting right now.
Yeah, they are.
I'm going to try to take...
I'm taking high ground here.
Yep, can you hold for me?
Yeah, I'm trying to hold.
I'm here.
I cracked one of them.
We have to push soon.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I got sniped.
I got sniped while falling down.
There's snipers under you guys.
There's two under you, two under you.
Oh, you have to defuse.
Yeah, or else...
Yeah.
One, one, one HP.
I don't think you have time.
I'm going to suck, I'm going to suck, I'm going to suck.
He's out, he's out, he's out.
Defuse, defuse, defuse, defuse.
Alright, did we get it?
Wait, why isn't it defusing?
I was holding F like seven times.
Goodbye.
Wait, no, no, no, it's fine.
It's a pity run, it's a pity run.
Dude, it broke.
I was holding F and the bomb just destroyed that thing.
No, no, no, no.
It thought you were ruzzing someone, that's why.
Because their teammate was near the bomb.
So he griefed me.
I think you should pull back if their whole team is on you.
I'm just going to B.
Yeah, I'll go A then.
Someone has to go A.
Yeah, I'll go A.
Yeah, sure, you should.
I'm just putting this turret in.
I'll go A.
I'm with you.
They're B, they're B.
Three B, three B.
I'll stay in mid, I'll stay in mid just in case.
They always push this shit mega hard though, so be careful.
I see them, one in mid.
I see one in mid.
That's two mid.
Two mid.
They're all towards B right now.
They scanned me, they scanned me.
Oh, they might all push you, you guys should back up.
Yeah, I know, I'm backing up right now.
Mid,
mid.
They're going to come in.
Oh, no, they're right, they're going to B.
They're coming to you, they're coming to you, they're coming to you, Matt, they're coming to you.
They're coming to you.
Wait, they're all there.
He's cracked, he's cracked, he's cracked.
One's on site, one's on site.
One's on site, I can't get him.
They smoked me, they smoked me, so I can't do anything.
I'm heading over, I'm pushing through the smoke.
I got, I killed the guy B.
One B site.
I'm backing up.
I'm going heaven, going heaven, going heaven, going heaven.
This guy, this guy, this guy right in front of us, there's literally a guy right in front of us here.
What the, oh, the sniper pushed me.
Yeah, wait, he got someone, dude.
I'm resable.
I'm pushing up.
I got one, I got one, I got one.
I'm playing for res.
It's just one left.
Last guy, last guy.
Their armor's broken.
Their armor's broken unless they got healed.
They're high ground.
They're probably regen.
Dead.
Nice.
Yay!
Alright.
I think we don't have a lot of, like, prize.
Oh, by the way, are you guys buying, um, light regen armor?
No, I buy heavy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I buy, oh.
Yeah, I buy light, I buy light.
I buy light.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Light regen.
Oh, I do not have enough money now.
I don't, I don't have armor.
No, wait, no, you have no armor now.
I have no armor, guys.
I, I, I blame our IGL for griefing me there.
I listened too well.
No, the fine print, I didn't say, I didn't say to sell.
I'm on A.
You're B?
Yeah, I'll stay A, I'll stay A.
I'm staying A to look at mid.
Uh, A, we can get a little more active.
We can, we can sit on the wall here.
We can sit on the wall here.
If they push up, we can try to jump one guy.
We can just like solo someone.
There's one, two, three.
Careful next.
Oh, there's two up there.
There's two up there.
Yeah, there's two, there's two.
We're gonna have, we're gonna have Surefour hold it.
Are you gonna hold our angle?
Yeah?
Uh, I need to get back up.
Yeah, there's three.
There's four.
Next one, next is gonna flank soon.
Next is gonna flank.
Oh, wait, no, they're never close.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, they're hard pushing.
They're hard pushing now.
I hit one for 156.
Above you, 156.
Dead.
He's down.
Another one, 152.
Another one.
Push him, push him, push him.
I got him, I got him, I got him.
Nice.
Headshot sniper up top.
Thirsted.
There's just one.
One left.
I threw a nade.
You can push that.
On me.
I threw a wind nade.
I hit one 58, 58.
Nice.
I'm flying.
I have it.
I have the turret.
Okay, now I can buy the regen.
Alright, I'm just gonna put my turrets and I'll go.
I'm going A this time.
Wait, really?
Under their heads.
Oh, okay.
I'll stay, I'll still stay in A then.
We can do the same thing, last round.
And if they don't come B, we can just flank them.
I'm waiting until...
Okay.
I think we're doing the same thing.
Yeah, we're doing the same thing.
God fuck damn it.
I told you.
They might come in.
There's one in mid.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I saw them.
I saw them too.
There's two mid.
They're coming over.
No, they're all here.
They're all here.
Okay, okay, okay.
They rotated.
One on top of mid.
I'm going from back here.
I don't feel safe.
Oh, they're coming in.
They're coming in.
I'm coming in.
159.
I'm heading over, I'm heading over.
There's a headshot sniper up top.
They're pushing me on point.
Yeah, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
One's broken armor again.
I got one, I got one, I got one.
I'm throwing a turret, I'm throwing a turret.
Turret's out, turret's out.
So like, it should help.
I'm wind grenading.
It's okay, they can't plant.
I have a turret.
Nice.
Yeah, the turret's nearly in there.
Dude.
Alright, I think you should stay in B.
Maybe you should stay in B.
But surely they go A this time.
We'll see, we'll see.
Let me put my little turret.
My little turret baby right here.
And then my other baby right here.
Okay.
I don't see anything top B.
I'm with next right now.
I think they're looking to rotate mid maybe.
I'm looking at mid right now for us.
Yep.
I'm C.
They're always rotating.
They're on top of A again.
Yeah.
Oh!
They're looking at mid.
My location's revealed.
Yeah, I don't know.
I'm mini rotating.
We don't know where they are, so it's kind of scary.
Mid, mid, mid.
How am I still the real?
One's top mid.
We can try to beam her.
Oh, no, nevermind.
Wait, they might come back.
One's on that wall right here.
Yeah, they're still looking.
They went back to B.
They're pushing you guys.
Yeah, they went back.
Oh wait, they're going back.
Run, run, run.
I got one.
Nice.
Do they know you're there?
They're going back.
They're hard pushing you.
Careful.
Nice ult.
I'm pushing.
Fuck it.
Okay, that's toxic.
Just get active.
I did something very toxic.
You're free.
Last round before the half.
Wait, should I get ADS speed or spread control?
What's the best?
Spread control.
I always get ADS speed.
You're not going to listen to your IGL?
No, no, no.
Snipers should get ADS speed.
Wait, I was muted that whole fucking time.
How long was it?
The entire time.
He thought you were just a silent warrior.
Yeah, I thought you were just a turtle locked in.
I can armor one of you with the heal drug.
What were you even saying?
I was like saying everything I was doing.
I've been comming with my bear where people are at.
I'm like droning B.
There's four B's right now.
Yeah, we heard nothing.
You were just vibing.
Okay, we're smoked off right now.
I droned you.
I wonder if I can get this.
Still droning it.
They're going mid.
Oh, I hit 64.
I frantically hit them.
Don't show yet.
Once they come mid, we can crunch them.
Oh, there go mid.
I saw one flying mid.
Just wait, just wait, just wait.
Oh, they don't know.
Two flying mid, two flying mid.
Two flying mid?
Okay, wait.
There should only be like three mid.
Three flying mid.
Yeah, there should only be three mid.
Doki doki, help.
How?
Rotating.
Okay, it's time to go.
I was.
I don't know where he got from there.
Yep, yep.
One, two, three, two, one.
There's three mid.
I'm like, how?
One down, one down.
Got the other one?
I don't even have to do anything.
I'm just here first.
Yeah, he's the insurance policy.
I'll play Celeste now.
You can play Ming if you want.
I'm a French maid now.
I have the legendary skin of Celeste.
Oh, that's true, that's true.
I might go for like a Batling Night angle or something.
It's a pretty long range map.
Alright, here we go.
Now we're attacking.
I don't know how to attack on this map.
Um, Regi is very good.
It's actually kind of a godsend that Abe started playing Regi.
I was always like, oh, he seems pretty good.
Did you build a wall?
His wall is very strong.
And once you get Awakening 3, we can see through the wall when we're close to it.
And they can't.
Alright, IGL, where do we do?
Which point?
We're going A.
Okay, nope.
Yeah, I listen to Sherpa.
He's the real IGL.
Now it's your turn to IGL.
Wait, Sherpa, yeah, do you want to IGL?
No, I'm a side IGL-er.
I'm the commander that tells everyone where to go, and then the squad leads lead the squad.
Um, when you reach the wall, we can reach the wall like this.
Um, these two things.
And then we can all take Bank.
Okay.
IQ.
Oh?
I got scan for Sniper.
Um, yeah, just make space for the reach wall.
I'm taking high ground.
Where am I walling from?
Oh.
Oh my god, goodbye.
Yeah, no, he destroyed me.
Um, from here...
I killed one.
Nice.
I'm five health.
I can't really walk up.
I have a healing nade for you.
Okay, I'm rezzing.
I need somebody to back us up.
I'm dead.
Honestly, wait, wait.
They're running at you.
Oh, they're dead!
Oh my god!
I died!
Oh!
Okay.
Yeah, they hard pushed.
Honestly, they won't.
Since we died, they won't think we'll do it again.
Okay.
They're gonna do it again.
Damn.
We have three rounds to lose until it's time.
God, no, no!
Don't say that.
We can't do that.
Guys, guys, guys.
Wait, next.
Where are you next?
I'm here.
Why?
What's up?
Oh.
Wait, that's so disrespectful.
What do you mean?
He's a team planter!
Oh, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Where is the sniper shooting from?
Window?
Um, on my ping.
On my ping here.
Oh, underside.
No, no.
He's on top.
This is the top side.
This is the top window.
Oh, gotcha.
You can also move to here.
Yeah.
I was looking at the top right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Does this game eat your guys' RAM usage?
Is my game?
It's literally peaking.
It's literally peaking 99%.
I'm alright.
I have no idea.
I have no idea either.
I just feel like I'm okay.
My whole computer is locking up.
Oh, no.
We can play a little slower, actually.
We don't have to force the wall out.
Yeah, because he's at the back side.
Yeah, we have three, like, semi-auto weapons.
So, we can just try to get a pick.
I found a sniper if you want to push.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can we try to push up for the Rachel?
Knock on site.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Push up for the Rachel.
One more site.
One more top site.
Top site.
They're probably going to rez.
I'm pushing up.
Yep.
One's top site.
I'm top of site.
I knocked one.
I think I almost cracked him.
I cracked him.
I think they're going to rez.
I don't have bomb.
Next has bomb.
Guys, I'll pop up.
He's low.
Oh my god.
Get him.
I got one.
There's another one on point.
There's one on top, yeah.
Yeah.
He's one.
Got another one.
It's 2v2.
2v2.
You can rez this, yeah.
Just cover.
Cover him.
Back!
Nice.
He's one.
Nice!
Nice.
Alright.
Honestly, I think we should... yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's just stop forcing the Rachel, I guess.
I think we're just way better at just killing them.
I think because Mac is playing at the very back side, so we have to wait for him to push up.
They might have someone playing mid.
So we can try to pick them off.
Wanna play super slow?
Yeah, we can play super slow.
Because we have three very long range weapons.
Me, Abe, and Shur4.
Okay.
I'm trying to move around and stuff.
Not gonna lie.
It's still very hard.
Yeah, when my ship fully locks up, it makes my inputs delay by 5 seconds.
It's really annoying.
You gotta lower your graphics?
Nah, it's my RAM.
My RAM is peaking.
It's literally 100% usage.
It looks like they're giving mid to us for free, so...
They rotated.
Oh, I got destroyed.
Wait, wait, wait.
Can you... wait, wait.
Follow me.
I don't have any more heals left.
Can you wall from where I'm standing to here?
One is up top.
Okay, okay, okay.
And then we're gonna... let's go, let's go.
Wait, their sniper fell off the map.
We just crossed to the left side.
How the fuck are they still alive?
Oh, they killed themselves.
They have no sniper A.
We're going B.
It's already too late.
I got him.
Dead.
He's underneath.
Yeah, I see, I see.
Oh, there's two behind me, but they're both low down there.
The people downstairs are low.
There's one that was behind me.
That's the last guy.
Last guy, last guy.
He's the last guy.
Oh, fuck, he's right here.
I bodied him, I bodied him.
He's... no armor.
Yeah, let's go!
Dude, I saw you getting shot from behind, so I pushed up to try and help you and you kept shooting me in my ass.
No, yeah, the guy that was shooting at me from behind.
I killed him.
I have all two.
Bad comms, bad comms, my bad.
I hit the 180, though.
Yeah, you did.
Yeah, that was pretty awesome.
Holy shit.
What, what are you laughing at?
Look at Tav.
Wait, I can make sure for bottom frag.
Do it up.
Alright, I'm heading over.
I'm just a little support.
I'm support too!
I'm just a little guy.
A little guy living in a little world?
Oh, bam.
He's trying to...
Should I break it?
Oh, we can leave, yeah.
Let's go, let's just go.
Or mid, let's go mid, yeah.
I'm with Mac.
Surefour is lurking right now.
I'm lurking.
Yeah, he's doing his thing.
Yeah.
Um, I think A is going to be open.
No, flank, flank, flank, flank, flank.
Nice, nice, nice.
That was a good pick.
Let's go A, let's go A, let's go A.
A window, A window.
Left side window.
I painted it, I painted it.
I hit him 70.
Oh, just keep going A, just keep going A.
Don't worry about the flank.
I'm visible here.
There's a flank right now.
Wait, who has bomb, who has bomb?
I have one on me.
Wait, I have bomb.
I have one for 105.
I have bomb, I have bomb.
I'm heading up.
Oh, I'm getting shot, I'm getting shot.
Oh, never mind.
No, I had bomb, I couldn't tell.
That's my bad.
I'm going to rez, I'm going to rez.
I can't hit this bitch with G paper.
He's coming, he's coming, he's coming.
No.
Oh no, I'm sorry.
He jumped out, he's on my body.
Last guy, last guy.
2v1.
He's directly under you, directly under you.
Right side.
Wait, I'm going to try to rez if I can make it.
Yeah, it doesn't matter.
I was like, who has bomb?
And then Nek said, I have bomb.
And I was like, really?
I know I had it.
2v1!
Nice.
Yay!
We have a game right away, by the way.
We have a...
Oh, no great.
Dude, I have so much damage, but no kills.
Okay.
It's fine, now I'm warmed up.
Nice.
Now, I'm warmed up.
I'm motivated.
Alright, now back to my girl.
I'm getting my food, BRB.
Alright, I'm going to open up my box.
Oh my god, I got a fucking sculpture?
Hello, my new wife.
Oh my god, have you guys been giving gifts to her, too?
Oh, no?
Okay.
I'm just by myself, I guess.
I always give my baby gifts.
I always give her gifts.
Oh yeah, prove it.
What's her oaf?
Uh, two?
Oh my god, didn't even give her one gift.
Wow.
That's fucked up.
Wait, I'll give her a bunch of gifts right now, actually.
You gotta pace it.
Don't love bomb her!
No, don't do that to her!
No, it's too late.
No!
I'm showering her with gifts.
I just doubled her oaf level.
She went from two to four.
Oh my god, I'm still at three.
I'm doing it one by one.
I want her to appreciate every single gift I've given her.
Are you telling me that she loves me more than you right now?
No, I'm saying you're love bombing her and you're manipulating her.
Oh, she wants a toy.
Here you go.
Have my toy.
Yeah!
Of course.
She's level three now.
When is our next game anyway?
Is it like...
I'm not sure.
Automatically a question for Steph.
Is there a B...
Oh, there is a B stream.
When is our next...
Oh wait, caps lock.
When is our next game?
No, type it in caps.
Okay, when is...
You point...
Type it in caps.
I already said yes.
Dude, I'm hanging out with my bitch right now.
Don't...
You call her your bitch?
Yeah, we close like that.
Oath level three and shit.
It's whatever.
Yeah, but...
But Aqua's oath level is four.
Yeah.
Yeah, she loves him more than she loves you.
She fucking doesn't.
Then why is it three?
Why is it three?
It's her!
Wait, wait, wait.
She ain't loyal.
What are you gonna say about that shirt, boy?
I'm becoming gay.
Hey, what's up, man?
Hey, what's up, cutie?
Oh my god.
Okay, she's still at level three?
How much does she want from me?
I'm giving her so much.
Thank you.
Can you actually swap girls or not, Aqua?
You know the most.
Oh, oh yeah.
In the CN client, you can.
But in this version, it's only...
We're forced to...
Dude, what the fuck?
Download the other client right now if you want to swap girls.
Exactly.
Oh god.
Oh, you know, I don't want...
Okay.
Oh, I got string theory?
My girl's smart.
Alright.
Oh, nice.
I got pretty...
Is that an icon?
Can't change my...
Oh my god, I got an icon that she gave me.
I need to hide my screen just in case.
I don't know what my profile shows.
Wait, how do...
What are you trying to hide, huh?
I don't know.
I don't want people to see my friend code.
What are you trying to hide, huh?
You got things to hide?
Yeah, I don't want random people to...
Yeah, you want me to show them your friend code right now?
Yeah.
Okay.
I didn't expect you to say that.
My anime girl left me.
I need a new hookup.
You need a new hookup.
I need a fucking rebound.
We got a new code.
Oh, yay.
Wait, how do I change my icon like all you guys?
How do you guys do that?
Trying to change my icon.
Like the banner?
Yeah, my banner and my icon.
If you click on the top left...
Yeah?
Wait.
Actually, wait.
Let me see if...
Is it player chip?
Oh, it's player chip.
I found it.
It's player chip.
Yeah.
Yeah, I found it.
Save.
Yeah, I want this to be it.
Oh my god, I get to have medals on too.
Oh my god, that's when you know she's my girl.
I get to put medals on it too.
That's my girl.
That's her.
Now I'm beautiful.
Look.
Look, guys.
Alright, let's paste this code.
I think the password thing doesn't work.
As long as no one leaves the code, no matter.
Yeah.
Alright, I'm in.
Are we defense?
I don't remember.
We are...
What did I roll?
For map two?
No, we're attack, right?
No.
We are...
Oh, we're defense.
Yeah, never mind.
This is your sniper map.
Bro, what if I spent all my money?
All my currency just to gamble though.
You already have everything you want.
What else do you want?
It's not about what I have and what I want.
It's about spending more.
So you have an addiction.
No, I can stop whenever I want.
But you know the old saying, every miner stops digging...
What?
Why are you guys being weird?
So slowly.
Every miner stops digging before diamonds.
You guys are the ones being weird.
It's spelled M-I-N-E-R.
Like Minecraft.
Okay, okay, Surefour.
I just don't know why you hesitated there before you finished the sentence.
I didn't hesitate.
You guys didn't even let me finish.
You just heard miner.
I'm freaking out.
You had a fucking three second hesitation.
It's not three seconds, bitch.
Why are you so defensive?
I don't understand.
What do you mean why am I defensive?
Surefour, you became...
I'm not Dr. Disrespect out here, bro.
You can dig your hole.
I mean, you're a miner, right?
You gotta go dig that hole.
Yeah, for Gamba.
Every gambler quits before they make it big.
Yeah, that's basically the quote.
Not every miner stops.
I was quoting the image of that guy with the pickaxe and he's quitting and walking away and there's diamonds right beside him.
He's a miner.
Is he mine?
What about like a cave crawler?
Who the fuck would say cave crawler?
Are you trying to say our IGL is weird?
Are you trying... how could you?
That's our IGL right there.
Anyone without green ping is weird.
Weird, weird.
I don't agree with that.
Doki's the only one with green ping.
Yeah, Doki's the only one with green ping.
What the fuck, this is bullshit.
They switched servers.
They're not even green either.
Oh, they swapped to West Coast.
This is West Coast.
That just means I'm half weird.
Trooper, get the fuck on our team.
No, I'm part of the enemy team now.
How are we mean?
We were just asking for clarification.
No, you weren't.
We were just trying to protect you.
We were trying to protect you.
I can't, I can't.
You've been so weird ever since you became gay, man.
Listen, next is someone we have to be careful about.
He lives in VRChat.
I don't, excuse you, I don't.
Yes, you do.
What do you mean?
You have no idea what I do in that game.
What do you do?
I'm not an anime girl.
I have a clip that you sent me.
Do you want me to post that clip?
Wait, what clip?
Hold on.
I can post that clip right now in our team chat.
Wait, which one?
Which one?
There's too many clips.
I'm throwing.
Alright, here's one of them that they sent me.
Wait, where did you post that?
It's in our team chat.
Oh, no.
Time to full screen it and watch it on Twitch.
No, don't watch that.
Look, it's RP.
It's RP only, okay?
It's fine.
Wait, no, I'm watching it.
What is this?
Wait, I gotta mute Discord to hear this.
You gotta mute Discord?
What is this?
Guys, if you guys...
I can post this in my chat right now, next.
That's all I'm saying.
Go for it, honestly.
It's funny.
This is what he said.
Alright, now you're gonna defend yourself?
Are you still gonna defend yourself?
Hell yeah, dude.
That shit's hard.
There you go.
You guys got the clip.
Anyways...
I can see why you're bottom fragging now.
Wait, wait, wait.
Bro, come on.
It's only RP.
It's just RP.
Sure, as an ex-VR chat player, what do you say about that?
Yeah, it fits his type.
It fits his type.
I'm just jealous, honestly.
I don't think that's the right word.
How many hours you got next?
Actually, not that many.
Hold on, let me see.
I think I just bet like a thousand something.
You just said a thousand?
I have 8.5K.
I've seen every archetype of VR chat player.
What kind of archetype is next?
What is he?
The best.
Like the horny femboy.
I'm not even horny.
Come on, man.
We saw the clip.
I like how you don't even defend the femboy part.
You just went like, okay, I'm not that part.
On stream, I'm known as something waver, so I'm not taking the femboy.
Wait, wait, wait.
Do you want to tell us?
What?
I'm known as the racist European femboy.
He's just included with two more titles.
I mean, to that extent, you're European.
I assume every European is racist.
It's just who I am.
Wait, what is Ethos typing in the world chat?
I don't know.
I close world chat.
Wait, I close world chat.
That's a reason.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'll screenshot it.
I'll screenshot it and send it in our team chat.
You're right.
I shouldn't be worried about Shurf.
Shurf is definitely not the one that's missing.
Oh, goddammit.
This is what we're going against.
We'll get more water.
You know, I would reply to that, but it gets a little bit above PG.
Oh, no.
Professional.
Wait, I just need to write, like...
Alright, I'm back.
Wait, how did my world chat unclose itself?
Hackers.
Oh, my god.
They're out to get me.
Dirty hacker mans.
Alright, guys.
Is Zyder going to be a 1 or 2, 9 or...
We're going to have an okay time.
We're going to...
No, we're going to have a great time.
Guys, it's not the final sponsor stream.
Guys, I accepted Lyric's friend request.
What?
Yeah, Lyric...
Oh, Lyric!
Oh, okay.
Lyric, okay.
I thought you meant something else.
What?
I thought I heard something else.
Wait, what did you... What?
What?
No, that's fine.
That's fine.
As long as it's not what I thought I heard.
What?
Oh, I have a friend request from Next.
I'm going to reject that real quick.
What the fuck?
I can't even get friend zones.
Hello?
Wait, can I get added by everyone?
If we win this game.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
If we win this game.
I'm kidding.
Why do you mean by that?
You're supposed to give us hope and inspiration.
I'm throwing.
All I need is Next's friend request.
You're throwing?
Why are you throwing, Surefour?
I'm throwing.
Why are you throwing?
I'm sick of it.
What are you sick of?
I'm unleashing my Bankai.
Oh my god.
What are we waiting on right now?
I don't know.
Oh, wait.
Ready up.
Start the match.
Don't we have like two more games after this?
No, it's this.
After this and then one game.
Because we've only played four games.
So this is like... Yeah, we only have one game after this.
It's just the same team, but like in a different map.
And then...
Oh, you mean this is the final match.
Yeah, this is the... This is the... No.
Yeah, match.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
And if we win both, then we're probably playing...
Day two.
Yeah, but that's in like a week or two, right?
I don't remember how many weeks.
Yeah, in a week.
In a week, yeah.
So we don't have to worry about that in a week.
Oh my god, I can get on VR after this.
Bro.
I'm not a VR chatter.
I don't get on it every day.
Oh my god, I can get on VR chat after this.
Actually, I'm not able to because I have bleeding in my head.
What?
How do you have bleeding in your head?
Wait, how... What happened?
VR chat happened.
No, actually...
Did your handband destroy your head or something?
Like, what?
Why are you here?
It was from dancing, wasn't it?
Why are you in the hospital?
No, it wasn't from dancing.
Let's just say I was playing VR chat, okay?
Wait.
So ERP got a little bit too bussy.
Oh, but how did that... How did it involve the head?
I mean...
We were trying some experimental...
Experimental positions, yeah.
Like, I legit have a huge headache right now because of that.
Wait, why aren't you at the hospital?
That's why you're bottom fragging.
Because, I mean, you know, who needs them, honestly?
I mean, you're in Europe.
Don't you have free healthcare?
Yeah, but like, what are they gonna do?
Oh, well, okay, well...
Stop the bleeding?
No, I know it.
What?
Wait, I don't even know you're fucking...
Wait, someone left.
Oh, yeah, they forfeit.
Let's go.
They forfeit?
They forfeit.
We got a number one victory royale.
Yeah, Fortnite, we're about to get down.
Get down!
Ten kills on the board right now.
Just wiped out Tomato Town.
My friend just got downed.
I revived him.
Now we're heading southbound.
I think they're switching servers.
Oh!
Oh shit, he knows the rest of it.
Of course!
He one-upped you.
I couldn't... I wouldn't take that.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Why are we instigating?
He's had too much pressure.
You can't blame him.
He literally is bleeding right now, so...
True, I am disabled.
I am really bleeding right now.
Guys, Trifor and I are both sponsored right now and I'm a little worried.
This is a great sponsor.
What the fuck do you mean?
I've been enjoying the content.
You are the content!
These conversations are what make people watch more.
That's true, that's true.
If you place Trinova right now and use my code, not Surefor's code, but my code...
We have codes?
You don't need to worry about Surefor, I think.
We got codes?
It's true.
The fuck you mean we got codes?
Okay, Surefor's chat, I have a tracking link on my stream right now.
Hey, don't click that shit!
Get out of here!
I have a tracking code that you too can click, guys.
Slashme puts up the walls?
None of you are allowed over there.
I'm mod, I can't...
I can post a link in your chat!
Unmod, time out for four hours.
No, no, no!
No, I'm dying!
Cleaning up the trash.
Wait, Surefor, I see that there's a new mods edition, can I get it?
Come back to me in four hours.
Yo, that's me right there, hi.
First message?
Not following?
Oh shit, bro.
There we go.
Timed out 14 days.
No, what the fuck?
1,209,000,000 seconds.
At least it wasn't my first message.
Hey, can I get mod though?
Not after that.
Hey guys, you guys saw my link for like 5 seconds.
So you can press that tracking link.
My name is Deez.
What the fuck do you mean?
Where's your tracking link?
I don't know.
What do you mean you don't know?
It's okay.
More tracking links.
I don't even know if I'm supposed to have one.
Yes, everybody is supposed to have a tracking link.
What the fuck do you mean tracking link?
It's okay guys, it's okay.
You guys can use my tracking link.
We're both sponsored.
And since he doesn't have it, I have this tracking link that you can press too.
You can't censor an audio, chill.
My tracking link is trenova.link.
I think I do have a link.
Oh my god, what do I get if I sign up with your code?
Is this the link?
I don't know.
I'm just posting chat.
I don't know what it does.
Is this trenova.link?
Yeah.
Yeah, that is the link.
Hey, I got a link.
Huge.
Where was it?
It was like there.
Someone didn't read their messages.
I did, but they just said I got a link and I thought that was just a link to the download.
Wait, that is your tracking link.
Guys, don't click his tracking link, guys.
No, click mine.
VTubers aren't real.
You're not real.
I'm real.
I have flesh.
I can turn on my webcam right now if I want to.
Do it.
Do it then.
Do it, yeah.
Show us your setup.
Yeah.
Alright.
Wait, where's my OBS?
Boom.
Show everybody that you're real.
I have flesh, unlike this fake amalgamation.
Oh my god.
You look just like you did when you played Overwatch back in the day.
Yeah, I think that's how, like, living works.
I don't think you're the same.
I've actually lost, like, 18 pounds.
Oh, shit.
Nice, good for you.
Thank you.
Wait, I'm going to... I'm going B.
Oh, it's this.
Why did we pick this map, guys?
I'll be up here, I guess.
I don't know.
I don't know how to defend this.
I know how to defend A more than B.
I don't think I've ever played this map.
Yes, you have.
That was our first game together.
Wait a minute.
Yeah, that was our first warm-up game together.
I want to say something, but I'm not going to say it.
We're going to say it.
Can you heal me?
We need to head over soon.
Yeah, we can.
You want to go for Heaven?
Yeah, I'm going Heaven.
Oh, she's right here.
What do you do?
I'm dead.
I'm going to crossfire.
Oh, I got body blocked.
I got body blocked.
Oh my god!
Guys, now I...
They know how I play this game, guys.
They know.
They have the movement.
I'm sitting down.
I'm very submissive.
Hey!
Nice trade!
So, what are you going to be doing, Trifor?
Well, I'm backup, so I don't look in the mirror anymore.
Where do I play?
AI, I guess?
Yeah, probably.
Alright, then I guess I'll play B.
I'm not used to playing B, but I'll try my best.
Alright, I'll be in this little cubby hole.
Guys, I think we're going to know how it feels to be that other team last game.
Nah, we're going to win.
Oh, they're right here again.
They're right here again.
They're going to put the wall up on my ping here.
They have, like, set lineups and setups.
This team has been scrimming for a long time.
They've been scrimming?!
Yes, they've been scrimming!
What?!
I'm blind.
Yeah, but Trifor and I are sponsored, so, like, who's winning?
I'm coming behind them right now.
Yep.
I'll push through.
I can't see anything.
I'm going for 139.
I'm going through the wall.
The one on pillar is one-shotting.
To your right, Toki.
Bottom right, bottom right, bottom right.
Okay, I can see him.
One side, he's focused on the other side.
I got him, I got him.
Last one, last one.
Bottom right, bottom right.
You can arrest people.
Yeah, I'm rezzing, I'm rezzing.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm rezzable, too.
I have, like, a...
They haven't planted yet.
We don't have to run at them.
I'm putting turret.
This player is very good.
Never mind.
Yeah, let's go!
Listen, I had someone in my chat say, Oh, hey, I recognize that team.
That is CN's server team.
All those guys are good at the game.
Yeah.
Wait, why are they in our lobby?
No, it's fine, it's fine.
Because we won a round, baby, and we're gonna win out.
Listen, listen, we won a round, we can win the game.
They should be playing against the other team that's on CN's servers.
Hey, stop freaking around.
We got a round.
We got gamers here.
I believe, I believe.
Guys, we got one round off the pros.
We're gamers.
No, no, no, we're pros, too.
I did so much damage that round.
I broke so much armor.
Okay.
Dude, they're not gonna go A again.
They're gonna C, they're gonna C.
They're gonna show Mac and Nex what they did.
Don't fight yet, don't fight yet.
I'm rotating.
They're pushing Nex right now.
Yeah, they're on me.
Shoot them, shoot them.
I can kill you, I can kill you.
He's one, he's one.
One HP, one HP, one HP.
I can heal you, I can heal you.
There's people on the side, there's people on the side.
I'm smoking, I smoked the closet.
Go in the room, go in the room.
I fucked up my name.
Follow me, come to me, come to me.
Okay, okay.
They haven't planted yet, so we don't have to over-aggress.
I ulted.
I don't see them, I don't know where they are.
We got bomb down.
I don't know how to ping.
Push with me, push with me, push with me.
I'm right there, I'm right there, I'm right there.
I'm holding this A, I'm holding this A.
You can arrest me.
Wait, surefour, come here, surefour.
Coming.
Oh, by me, by me, by me.
By me, right here, right here, right here.
Nex, you can try to kill Rachie there.
I'm backing up, I'm backing up.
There's two of me.
Yeah, I'm coming, I'm going there.
I'm ulting.
I'm getting the paper spot.
Oh my god.
They're pushing you, they're pushing you.
Yep.
They're coming out, they're coming out.
By me, by me, by me.
It's fine.
It's just one.
Yeah, let's go!
How did that miss?
Okay, see, we're already in the lead.
Come on, just focus.
Alright, let's try, let's try our best, guys.
I believe.
I start believing now.
Don't let me down, protector.
I've always believed.
Honestly, this is easy.
Hey, my drone gives armor now.
Nice.
Oh, big.
Okay, sure.
Sure, go to my ping.
Yeah, that's fine.
Hold my left.
Yep.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I didn't hit a single shot that round.
No, it's fine.
That's fine.
It happens.
Not everybody can, you know, frag out.
My name's Deez.
I don't see nobody.
Ayy.
Ayy, I'm heading over.
Whoa, what ult is that?
They might try to kill me.
Yeah, they're pushing, they're pushing, they're pushing you.
I threw the wrong nade.
Oh, they're gonna...
Can we just take Heaven?
I am... I naded.
Can you heal me?
Yeah, I can.
Ooh!
Are you guys okay?
I'm, I'm, I'm...
It's fine, it's fine.
I got revealed, so...
You might push through the wall.
Yeah.
I smoked on the left side of the wall.
They did push through the wall.
They're fishing.
Someone push us over.
She's on the box, she's on the box.
Oh, I can't see, I can't see.
I can't see now.
I'll try to, I'll try to rez you if I can.
But I'm in a very bad spot.
Yeah, I literally can't see.
I'm dead.
They're pushing, they're pushing behind you, Aqua.
Yeah, yeah, I see them.
They're going Heaven, they're going Heaven.
Two on top, two on top left.
Wait, I'm, I'm, I'm gonna go.
One, one, one, I got one.
Like, not one, he's one HP.
No, he's one HP, I didn't get him.
Nice.
There's one more here, one more here, one more here.
Oh, he's so low.
I don't think we... yeah, they got the point.
Oh, yeah, that was really hard.
I accidentally threw my whirlwind grenade instead of my anti-air grenade.
Oh, that's unlucky.
I have, I have turret for retake.
Um, yeah, yeah, that's fine, actually.
Just do the same setup.
Um, Abe, can you stand over here to, to, like, watch this or to watch them, like, push up Ceylon?
Yeah, I usually, I just throw a bear on it.
Oh, no, you don't have to throw a bear.
You can just use the bear for, um, like, utility when you're retaking site, or, like, um, holding it.
Because the vulnerability is very, very low.
Okay, I'm chilling.
I don't see anything, Cey.
A?
Yeah, I'm rotating already.
I'm heading over.
I'm gonna push, Cey.
Okay.
Uh, we're, we're gonna, we have a long flank, so it's gonna take a while.
Um, they might try to push us before.
64 on one of them.
Um, wait, can you, can you, can you, can you, can you, Michelle, up here?
I got pushed though, I got pushed.
I'm pushing, I threw my ult, I threw my ult.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm getting thirsted.
I'm trying to get to you.
I hit him a little bit.
No, I threw.
Wait, they revealed me.
Nice.
There's one in heaven right now.
Just be careful.
Oh!
Oh, he got me, yeah.
In heaven, in heaven.
Uh, one is watching flank.
Yeah, I shouldn't have pushed that.
That was too much of an ego push there.
I'll play more safe.
They might go A, guys.
Yeah, I'm just going to give you a turret.
I'm going to give turrets at...
I don't think I can play there reliably.
No, you can play there, you just have to give it up, like, way faster.
I'm just going to play a turret.
Like, you can take one or two shots, but when they, like, come in to, like, you, you can, you can just leave.
Alright.
You have so much util.
Holy fuck.
Nothing C again.
Yep.
Nothing B.
Uh, A.
Guys, they might be going A.
They might be going A.
Wait, wait, wait, um, start, think about fighting down here, I think.
I'm, I'm, I'll pop my ult, and we'll fight there.
I'm heading over then.
Yeah, I'm here, I'm down, I'm heading over.
Oh, my, my, my turret's up.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
I have rez.
I'm going to bear.
They, they put a mirror.
I, I don't know how, if I should push through it.
Uh, wait, wait, wait.
It's two bottom right, two bottom right.
Don't, don't push through it yet.
I can rez.
There's one high ground.
I hit, I naded somebody.
Nice.
Wait, I'm.
Oh, I got.
There's one right in front of you.
He's one, he's one.
Oh, I got crossfire.
There's a cross, nice.
I got one, I got one.
There's two, there's two here, there's two here.
I'll knock behind you next.
Sure, four, yeah, sure, four.
You can.
Yeah, I'm coming.
One on, one on right there, sure, four.
Two, two, two.
Nt, nt.
Uh.
That's fine, that's fine.
Wait, am I not invisible when I'm in my bear?
No, you're not, you're not entirely invisible, I think.
You're like, you're like, just like, somewhat transparent.
Um.
I'm just going to give you guys my turret.
I feel like they're just hard, always going in.
Oh yeah, sure, for your character, by the way, she can, she has the, she's the only one who can like, she's like lifeline.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
She can lifeline right through.
I pressed F on you and nothing happened.
Oh no, it just, it just takes a while for it to, but it's like automatic, so you don't have to pay attention.
Yeah, yeah, I know that part.
But.
Otherwise, I don't, we're not doing too bad.
Whoa.
I just have to shoot him in the head.
Nothing to see again.
Yeah, I think they're just going A over and over again.
Yeah, they're just going A over and over again.
I do have turrets up.
Oh wait, no, there's.
Oh no, they're going B.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, they saw me.
Ooh, just keep running, just keep running, just keep running.
Help me, help me.
I'm trying, I'm trying, we're trying.
I'm throwing nades too.
I might kill one here.
Oh, I'm back here by yourself, careful.
I killed one.
Nice, nice.
See if you can kill two, that'd be so awesome.
Oh, they're on site.
One's close as fuck on me.
They're planting, they're planting.
I don't have, I don't have, I don't have.
One's on my ping.
I don't even know where they are.
Oh my god, they have walls here?
Okay.
Wait, he just hit me.
I'm not going to make it.
Yeah, I think he has the thing that lets him see through walls.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, they have the upgrade that lets them see through the wall.
Okay.
Because I was going to say, like, how did he see me?
Um.
With how we're playing, flanking takes too long right now.
So, either we wait for the flank or, or we just, um, don't flank at all.
I've just been flanking because I'm usually leaning forward more than I am back.
So, it's like the fastest way for me to even get back.
I'll just play A now.
Wait for you guys.
Okay, I'll, I'll see.
Oh, let's see, let's see, let's see.
Oh my god.
Oh, see?
That was fast.
Oh, they're going to come up.
They're going to come up on my ping.
They're up C, they're up C.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, we can't help them.
Yeah, I'm dead as fuck.
I'm going to run in and see what happens.
There's people right in front of you guys.
Yep.
Let's go over there.
How do you do this?
Oh, we can try to kill them.
Yeah.
I'm looking to our right, right.
I'm out for you guys.
Bruh.
I hit one from 180.
I got, I got one, I got one.
There's one more here.
One more on you.
Triforce.
Behind you, behind you, behind you.
Oh no.
It's up to you.
Last one.
Unlucky, unlucky.
Okay, two six.
Could be better.
Maybe I don't, maybe I don't pick a sniper rifle.
They don't seem to let me be shooting them.
They know.
They know you're the strongest sniper.
They're putting all the util on you.
Yeah, I love you.
Good ball.
If you don't want to play a sniper, but yeah, you can play a sniper.
I'm committed.
You're committed?
I fuck with that.
All it takes is one.
All it takes is one point.
That's all.
See, they have a sniper rifle too.
Yeah, because we're in defense.
What do you mean?
They're on defense.
They should be.
I need these.
Very grateful.
Bro, they threw like 16 bubbles, 5 of them reveal you, 5.6 of them blind you.
The worst part is like the third person makes it so I'm blind even though I'm in front of the fucking thing.
No, yeah, this game.
This game, you just get like...
It's so hard to deal with if you don't have your own.
It's okay, sure, 4.
We can go...
You had those two kills.
That's all that matters.
Oh, you had that one kill and that's all that matters.
We can try going A as well.
The wall that they've been putting down is that they put their Ritchie in sewers and they throw the wall like to here.
Yeah.
All right, now it's your turn to do the same thing.
Locking.
Oh, I guess not.
I guess not.
That was hard.
I guess we don't do that.
I think they knew our strat, guys.
They knew, they knew, they knew.
They knew, they knew.
I think...
Okay, okay.
Maybe we should go another point because they think we're going to copy their strat.
Okay, let's go C.
So the C, the Ritchie wall, that's C.
You go sewers as well.
And you put your wall like here.
Or here.
I think.
Oh, wait, is it?
Is it?
No, it's from here to here.
Yeah, we'll figure it out.
We'll figure it out.
I believe in you, Mac.
Yeah, I've got a pretty good idea.
Yeah.
This guy knows how to make lines.
Oh, we need the bomb.
He goes to land.
Something like that.
I don't think we need the bomb.
What do you mean by that?
We won't get to the point, it doesn't matter.
Like, will we get to the point first?
Like, that's what I want to know.
I only hit the guy once, apparently.
Oh, you can put the wall down.
Yeah, split site.
Yeah, nice.
Just go through.
Just play left side.
We need to get control of back site.
Yeah, can you watch my TP?
What?
Nice.
Oh, I see someone over there.
In the room, in the room.
Oh, there's someone on next.
There's someone on next.
Yeah.
I'm going to look at our flank, just in case.
Oh, that's like three.
That's like three over there on my ping.
Three?
Oh, well, shit.
Oh, shit!
We have bomb down.
Behind us!
Oh, one flank.
One flank.
Oh, guys, we have one more.
Guys, we get to play one more round, then we'll get to do the next map.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
No, what do you mean one more round?
We got like 13, because we're going to win all the next ones.
Wait, can we have the...
Please don't make us wait too long for the next map.
I'm ready to go.
Yeah, actually.
I'm ready.
What the fuck do you mean?
Kill these guys!
Yeah, there you go.
That's the passion we need.
No, as in like, I don't want to have an intermission.
That's what I mean.
You're already thinking about the next game.
We're in this game, Donkey Bird.
We're in this game right here.
We still got six more rounds to go until we hit overtime and win the game.
I just don't want to wait in between intermission.
We've been waiting like 15 minutes for intermission.
I agree.
Let's go again.
Let's try the same thing.
Honestly, it kind of worked.
We just got flooded by people here.
They just pushed through smoke.
Oh, so I'm going to go in.
Why didn't we push through smoke?
He's close.
I hit him 160.
Nice.
He's on top of the box.
Yeah, you can put the wall down.
I'll watch for you.
He's going to try to catch you.
Wait, I have the bomb.
They're going CT.
Okay.
Yeah, you have bomb.
I'm planting.
Oh, there's a person there.
There's a person right here that's just jumping.
He's low.
I got one.
Wait, wait, wait.
I broke that one's armor.
Fuck me, man.
I don't have heals.
Oh, fuck.
Careful, I don't have heals.
Oh, I'm just dead.
Oh, God.
They're going to flank again, aren't they?
No, they are.
How does that not hit?
I'm getting angry.
This guy's trying to do jump shots on me, man.
They're doing trick shots on you.
They're actually doing trick shots.
Let's go, Ata.
Nice, nice.
I got blue stuff.
Oh, my God.
They actually did a trick shot.
I saw him.
Yeah, but they missed.
They missed.
So, you won.
You won that mental fight.
You didn't get clipped, so...
They're not getting clipped.
They won't get a clip on me.
You won the mental game here.
Bro, what does it say?
I only did 78 damage.
I broke so many shields.
Does shield not count as damage?
I guess not.
That's your damage score.
You have 1800 damage.
Okay, we're attack next game.
So, we should...
Are they swapping servers again?
What's going on?
No, they're leaving so we can swap teams.
I was gonna say.
They can start now.
Why are you requesting to swap with me?
Ignored.
No, swap with Gengu.
No, I was getting requested by Alverelli.
I think he misclicked.
Why is there two...
Okay, I was gonna say.
You can start now.
We're good for three.
Start now.
Hey, wake up!
Dude, I'm dying.
Wake the fuck up.
Walk in.
Why are you dying?
I died.
I started getting hit with a migraine in the middle of this round.
I'm dying.
Oh, no.
Do I have to commit to the sniper rifle again?
Honestly, I think you lose if you don't commit to it.
So, I think you should commit to it.
You lose the war if you don't commit to it.
And you're trying to say that they made you swap off of sniper because you were weak.
You don't want to be weak.
You don't want to be weak, surefour.
I'm hitting a 360.
If I hit a 360 and headshot, I'm saying scrim this.
Scrim this.
You're going to fucking...
Dude, I can't even see world chat.
They can't even...
There's no global chat in game.
No, there is.
If you hit enter, you can talk to the other team.
Oh, we can talk to the other team?
Really?
If you hit enter and hit tab, you can talk to the other team.
In game, though?
In game?
In game, yeah.
Okay, surefour, you have to hit that.
Gentlemen's...
Wait, how do you spell gentlemen?
Are you trying to say how to spell gentlemen?
No util.
Pure FPS skills.
I think that's a great idea.
Test our pure FPS skills.
No util.
Guys, they didn't respond.
I got left on read.
No, we didn't.
Like, no abilities?
Oh, yes.
No abilities.
Guys, I don't think they're going to...
They said they're down!
Let's go!
I can snipe now.
Okay, what is the best, like, character to do that?
This guy's trying to metagame.
What the fuck?
Of course he is.
We gotta beat them.
Okay, now that's pure FPS.
We gotta have guns that can do damage.
Yeah, yeah.
Guys, but what if they lied to us?
What if they lied to us, guys?
If they lied, then what can you do?
No...
Smoke plus nade.
Smoke, nade, and no ability, right?
Yeah, smoke plus nade.
Smoke, frag, and flashes.
No abilities.
Only one util each.
Just no... Okay, now we're playing tactical shooting.
Now we're playing the game.
Now we're playing a real game.
You can't scrim this.
Yeah, we're beating them with our...
On our pure FPS skills.
And before one of the admins say, guys, you're not allowed to do that.
Wait, wait, wait.
If we actually do this, Abe, you should play Audrey.
She's the most gun character ever.
Wait, Max should play... Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because we don't need the wall anymore.
Dude, what if the casters can't read the chat and don't realize why no one's using abilities?
What if someone uses an ability?
They die.
How the fuck did you throw a forfeit?
If you use ability, you stand in the middle of the zone and...
And die in shame in front of everyone.
Oh, someone left.
Wait, why'd he leave?
They're already scared.
Yeah, he couldn't take our pure aura.
I got a spiritual pressure.
Alright.
They're gonna...
They should let us.
There's no way.
There's no way they do this to us.
What the fuck are...
Okay, there's no way they would do this to us.
Oh, they're gonna try to put...
Oh, they're trying to put a 3000 cooldown.
3000 second cooldown on the abilities.
That's not good enough because you can still use it once.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
It's their fault if they use it once.
That's cheating.
True.
Oh, yeah.
Who has the best passive abilities?
Because, yeah, you can't...
Oh, that's true.
Okay, let's condition.
Okay, I'm looking at the agents.
What do we play for passive?
I know who I'm playing.
Oh, Celestia.
Celestia, like, when she's around her teammates, she...
She heals?
Yeah, she regens.
Okay, I'll play Celestia.
And Audrey is a very good gun character.
Yeah, I'll do Audrey.
What's Max doing, Audrey?
Oh, are they?
Okay, my bad.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, Max is doing...
Audrey.
Yeah, Max has been practicing Audrey, yeah.
My computer is blowing up, so...
Turn off Throne and Liberty, then.
Dude, it's not open.
I wish it was.
All I have open is this game, my OBS, VTS, and Discord, and my RAM is actually maxed out.
No, Fuchsia's passive is also very good.
Like, she kills the guy.
Oh, so then...
She heals, yeah.
Next can save Fuchsia.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Michelle... Michelle just has a really good gun, so you can play her.
Oh, I should just play Michelle?
Okay.
Or you can play Celestia.
I'll just play Michelle, then.
I'll just keep going with Michelle.
Does my turret count as an ability?
Yes.
Oh, wait.
Wait, are we ready?
Team A, ready?
Yes.
Yes, we're ready.
Alright, we all figured... No, no, only smoke... Remember to equip smokes and frags instead of...
Yeah, smokes and frags.
I swear to God, if they... If they fucking... I'm gonna fucking call them out.
Wait, A, ready up.
We can't start it.
You have to hurry up.
He's so out of it.
He's not ready.
He's so cooked right now.
He's so cooked.
There we go.
Dude, it's... It's bad.
It's like I've got a hangover and now I'm cooked.
Oh my God, he even lagged on Discord.
Dude, no.
My computer's trying to kill itself.
Oh my God.
It's so over.
Kill yourself, you're so sexy.
Alright.
Oh yeah, remember to change...
Smoke, frag.
Smoke, smoke, frag.
Remember?
Wait, no, Ava.
I thought you were playing Andre.
Am I?
Oh yeah, you're right.
Oh my God.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
We're locked in.
We'll see if everyone is proper role players or not.
There's only one good option here in your loadout with smoke, frag.
And what is that option?
We're about to see if everyone picked it.
Alright, let's see.
I'm rank one role player here.
I have smoke, frag.
We'll see here.
Why did they pick that girl?
Isn't that...
Okay.
No, the pink girl.
Isn't pink girl mostly util?
Yeah, she is.
But her gun is also very good.
Alright, who got a knife?
Who got their knife?
Oh, no knives.
Only me, huh?
I got a deagle.
I got the deagle, though.
Yeah, you got the deagle, yeah.
Yeah, I got the deagle.
I'm fucking RPing.
Yeah, but you guys can't take your...
I run faster with my knife.
You guys don't.
I don't think you do, actually.
I do.
It's RP.
Let him RP.
I'm sorry.
Sine.
Castilla.
Wait, who has the bomb?
Oh, next.
Next.
Okay, here we go.
Smoke, frag.
This is all pure FPS skills right now.
This is tactical shooting.
I don't know how to... Wait.
I think we're descending at B.
Fuck it.
Oh, fuck.
He just hard pushed my ass.
I'm good.
Suppressing fire.
Get him up.
They're smoking.
Wait.
I used my ability.
I'm about to swing the smoke.
Wait.
Why did no one pick me up, man?
I literally died.
It was muscle memory.
We had...
We...
How do you type?
Competition?
Probably.
Teammate.
I'm ashamed of my teammates.
Wait.
It was a missed input.
Okay.
Here we go.
We all stopped fighting just to execute.
I'm ashamed.
Here we go.
Okay.
The bomb.
Hold on.
I got it.
We don't need the bomb.
We just need to fucking fight.
I need it for comfort.
Starts on swinging this shit.
Yup.
They're going to be flanking already.
They're pushing hard.
I'm looking at our flanks.
Flanking.
Oh, we traded.
I'm just as good as you.
Go back.
I'm rezzing.
I'm just as good as this guy.
I killed the flanker.
They're pushing me.
We're vibing.
Wait, they're nading.
Wait, we were not vibing.
Wait, yo.
I think they rezzed.
We were not vibing.
What the fuck happened?
What happened?
I body shot.
It all came crashing down.
I got a kill.
What happened?
Oh my god.
Guys, I...
That's it.
I'm going A.
Guys...
I think it's just an A and go right now.
I mean, Surefour can snipe through A.
You know?
Yeah.
I think you should...
I thought with pure skill, this would be a bit easier.
But like...
It ended up being a little bit harder, guys.
They should have upped the sniper rifle damage.
So it's AWP damage.
One shot body shot all the time.
Wait, wait, wait.
Surefour, Surefour.
If you get Awakening 1, you can...
If you full charge, you one shot body shot.
I... Oh, wait.
But Awakening doesn't exist in CS.
True.
Yeah, but it's automatic.
It's automatic, though.
Behind, behind, behind.
Up on the building.
I got a fucking knife.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Fuck it.
I'm swinging sight.
No, he just destroys me.
No, they have fucking crossfires, man.
Bro, they're actually playing CS, bro.
What do you do?
Yeah, what do you do when they play CS?
Wait, we're not playing on their map, too.
It's Dust2.
This is Dust2.
Cheaper.
You can't fucking go on that off angle to top left in Dust2.
What the fuck is that?
Wait, maybe we're playing an old version of CS.
Guys, I thought you guys were...
Guys, I thought you guys were CS players.
What happened?
I'm not.
Fuck CS.
I play Valorant.
That explains everything.
They're obviously overconfident.
We just have to wait for their pushes.
What if we all just rat in this room?
We all stay as paper form and see what happens.
Yeah, in that top right corner.
Right out there.
I'll be looking.
This is a beautiful little spot.
Yeah, this is...
I'm just...
This is gonna work out.
Wait, surefour...
He's 1v1ing.
Come here, Doki.
Be a part of the cult.
Yeah.
Goodbye, Surefour.
You lost your 1v1.
You lost your 1v1, Surefour.
No, no, no.
I re-peeked it because I wasn't a bitch.
No, no.
Well, now you're a dead bitch.
Yeah, now you're dead.
Hey.
But I had no bitch, though.
I don't think they're gonna push up, guys.
They will, 100%.
If they're not bitches, they'll push up.
Should we tell them to push up?
No, because they don't know.
That would be too obvious.
Don't figure it out.
Guys, we have a minute left.
No, I don't know.
Get his ass.
Yeah!
Behind!
It's winnable.
We got one.
That poor guy.
I re-peeked, I ain't no bitch.
Wait, I have an idea.
You guys all go there and I hide in a different area.
Wait, wait.
What if we hide here?
Just right behind the pillar.
Just right behind it.
Wait, just come in from the right side so they don't see you going up.
What if I hide here?
He said nah.
I'm going to watch Surefour die again.
I'm going to die again.
I don't give a fuck.
Let's go, let's go.
He's just trying to do his 1v1, but he's losing to it.
Wait, no.
I didn't know I could pop up.
They don't know shit.
They don't know that there's three of us.
There might be a little suspicious.
You could be up there?
Surefour.
We got to help him.
I'm smoking.
I'm smoking and giving you every util I have.
I just need you to know that.
I didn't even know you could go up there.
There's one coming my way.
Peekaboo, bitch.
Yeah, I got you, bitch.
Wait, wait, wait.
It's winnable.
I'm right back in the spot.
I have ult.
Where is Rezzing?
Rezzing.
They don't fall for it twice.
Surely.
You went up first.
Peekaboo.
Oh my god.
There's one more.
No.
This is it.
1v2.
He's just third person peeking.
Wait, wait, wait.
SharePoint.
Are you okay, SharePoint?
All I need is one.
All I need is one shot.
That's it.
I think they're better CS players than us, guys.
They might be better CS players.
I have to hit a headshot, man.
The only kill the other sniper has is me.
Because I repeat.
Because I ain't no bitch.
Guys, I think that's Cope.
I think that's Coping right now.
I knew it was happening.
I just forgot.
Wait, surely they don't expect it again, right?
Surely they don't expect it again.
Yeah, they wouldn't be ready for me to be here again.
Come on.
There's no way.
Okay, let me know.
I'll say.
Surefour is good for one.
He's good for one.
Bro, they're not peeking!
They're not peeking!
I got CS Code!
It's fine.
There's one walking up.
He's not okay.
Nice.
Shoot his body.
Behind us.
I don't know where.
How did he get back?
Below me.
I got him.
I got one!
I got two!
I fucked up my nade.
Where are they?
They're under you.
360!
Surefour, please.
Wait.
One more.
Okay, Surefour, please.
Please.
Peek-a-pussy!
You're such a bitch!
We did it!
We reached!
I jumped down to finish him off and I did kill him.
You're supposed to float!
If you float, you don't die to fall damage!
Oh yeah, true.
Did anyone see that 360 though?
Yeah, I did.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Guys, it was supposed to be pure skill.
Guys, what happened?
Hey, look.
Who's MVP right now?
Just saying.
For now.
What the fuck?
What are we doing?
Same thing?
I think they know now.
I'm a rat.
Oh dude, I'm dead.
No, no, no, no.
He's dead.
There's a stupid fucking fan there!
Resable.
I'll smoke.
I'll smoke and we'll cross and we'll go.
Resable.
I'm upscooting right now.
Oh, right here!
And right behind us!
I just got fucking resed, bro.
I'm pinging.
It's up to you next.
You got this.
I got one.
Guys, we don't...
Why is there a fan there pushing my ass?
Because you can fly up there.
Guys, maybe we can get another round.
Triforce, you're not top frag anymore.
I'm top D's though.
I can see my bloomers right now.
Oh my god.
He has a dress on.
This is not even...
We're not even using util either.
We're just going here.
Bro, we have to survive before we use util, man.
Smoke window.
Fuck him.
Wait, he's inside the smoke.
I killed him.
He's dead.
I thirsted.
Top mid on our left.
What is that angle?
What?
Oh my god.
He's dead.
Winnable.
Next, they're pushing you.
Wait, you guys are dead?
Yeah, you're dead too apparently.
Let's have a good time.
We got him on the defense.
Make sure you switch your util.
Make sure you get your knife out.
Get the knife.
Do you guys want to go knife only?
Knife round.
First round.
Got my smoke.
Get your smoke and frag.
You have an interceptor.
Fuck.
If you have it, just don't use it.
True.
Yeah.
Alright, knife round.
Alright, I'm getting...
Knife mid.
I'm getting the high ground.
Oh yeah, true.
Now we're playing actual tac shooters.
The roleplaying is so insane.
Is it two left click, one right click?
I don't know actually.
I don't know the meta for knifing in this game.
Alright, here we go.
Knife mid, knife mid, let's go.
Where are they?
They're not even mid!
Can we execute ethos?
Alright.
Where is he?
He's gotta be the first to die.
First to die, get him out, get him out.
Let's go, let's go.
Now we got the nuisance.
Now we knife round.
Left side, left side.
Get his ass.
There's both!
Look at him on the high ground.
Let's go!
There's one below.
He's so low, he's so low!
Hit your knives, hit your knives, let's go!
Right click!
Let's go.
And that's how we knife round.
Surely we went out now.
Now we win every game after that, right?
Alright, that's the motivation we needed.
Back to normal.
Let's tag B because honestly, I don't think we can hold even a single point.
Dude, I'm eager to push.
You can't ego push your sniper!
That's exactly why he can't.
That's a forward pusher.
This is the comeback.
This is it, I believe.
I'm gonna smoke and sit in it with my sword.
That's so real.
Wait, what if we just keep throwing smokes down?
Okay, I think they went A.
Oh, they went A.
They have no idea.
One just flew top.
He randomly papered at the perfect moment.
He just knows.
Ow, get out.
Is there somebody back here?
I got one.
On me, there's one knocked.
Oh shit!
Can you rez me?
I just saw him.
I literally just saw him.
That shit was scary.
I'm getting this, motherfucker.
Did you get him?
No.
He's just sitting there, paper marbling my ass.
Oh my god, he's coming with the knife!
What do you do?
Guys, this is it.
This is the comeback right here, right guys?
This is it.
This is the one.
Guys, this is it.
This is where it turns around.
What did he go A again?
My name is Deez.
Funnily enough, my headache's gone away.
All I'm saying is that we got the mental win.
We won knife round.
Motherfucker, you were saying, I hope there's not an intermission last game.
Before it was even over!
What did he go B?
Wait, wait, you're so wrong.
What angle is that one, guys?
I'm gonna rat.
They'll just be like, where is this guy?
Guys, I think...
This is the fucking dirtiest head peek ever!
Oh, they're A.
They're coming A.
Go back, go back, go back.
B to mid, B to mid, B to mid, B to mid.
They're here, they're here.
Run away, run away, get ready.
Go, go, go, go, go!
Did he jump off?
Did I just saw him jump off?
Nex killed himself.
They told me to get out.
WHAT I DID?
Oh my...
Did we even jump off?
NOOOOOO!
They told me to kill myself, so I did.
That poor guy on the roof just got jumped.
We got two rounds.
Combined total of four rounds, guys.
Guys, we did it, guys.
That's a dub, that's a dub.
Did you get your 360 headshot?
Did you get it?
I got a 360 body shot, though.
Oh god, I don't know what you were going to say.
Were you going to say something in chat?
Well, I didn't get the headshot, so I can't say it.
Dude, they fucking kicked me!
Is that it?
That's it.
They even kicked us out of the lobby.
We're free.
I don't think we're Day 2.
I think we had to win to get Day 2.
So we're free.
Yeah, we're free until Day 2.
Wait, no.
Doki's trying to say we don't get a Day 2.
Did we not get a Day 2?
No, we're getting into Day 2 because we beat the other team 2-0 and they didn't win a single game until...
Oh, so it grabs two teams.
Alright, guys.
GG's.
Can we replace our 6 with our sub?
Our 5th, sorry.
We have the chemistry.
We can't ruin the chemistry now.
Exactly, yeah.
Yeah, we have the chemistry going.
It'd be weird to lose the IGL.
Maybe I don't play Sniper every time.
Maybe, sure.
If you guys ever want to practice...
I'll see you on Day 2.
I'll see you on...
And I think Surefour's going to be on Deadlock anyway.
Oh, yeah.
That's fine.
I respect that.
Alright, GG's.
I had a great time, though.
I had a great time.
Thanks, guys.
Thanks for joining my team.
Surefour, can I get unbanned?
I don't want to type while you play Deadlock.
I'm such a big fan.
Surefour, give me mod or I'm modding you on my channel.
You already got it back, bitch.
Oh, did I?
Yeah, you ain't even paying attention.
I didn't know I was in a game with you.
I'm slick with it.
Thank you.
Guys, I got my mod powers back.
I'll pay $10.
Bro, you weren't even followed.
You're staying banned.
I followed instantly, man.
Come on.
You should've followed before I clicked that.
Not following.
GG's, everybody.
Click my link.
I had a great time.
I'm telling my shit.
Boom.
Overruled.
I had a great time, everybody.
I'll see you guys on day 2.
GG's, guys.
Maybe I won't.
I actually don't know if they're going to replace me.
We'll find out.
We'll find out on day 2.
Bye-bye, guys.
Bye.
Oh, my God.
That was really fun.
I had a great time, guys.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
Guys, there was no...
We tried to make the best...
Guys, we tried to...
Make it...
The best of it...
Guys, that team...
Has been playing on the CN server...
Since the beginning.
They've been screaming, guys.
We tried the best...
We could...
With our pure skill.
Guys, we got the knife round.
And by getting the knife round...
That means we won the war.
Okay.
Knife round was the pure skill round.
Actually...
We got content.
And that's all that matters.
But that was really fun.
I had a great time with my team.
I had a great time with our team.
And I had...
It was really great.
Huge shout-out to Stranova for sponsoring me and giving me the captain slot.
I loved all my teammates that played with me today.
They were all incredibly fun to play with.
Great banter.
Great comms.
Great pure skill.
Going on in there.
I can't believe...
I can't believe we were like...
Pure skill.
If we didn't win the knife round...
We could've done even worse than the round.
With the YouTube...
It's okay.
But we won the knife round though.
We won the knife round, guys.
Anyway...
Please, if you want to support me and the stream...
Please check out the link that's in my description.
And also pinned on my chat.
So, yeah.
Click on that link.
It really does help the stream and the channel.
Regarding future sponsorships.
And future strong sponsorships.
So, yeah.
Click on the link for us.
But yes, thank you again.
Thank you again to all my teammates.
For playing with us.
Anyway, I will not be streaming for the next two days.
Because my voice is dying.
Not dying, but like...
I need a rest.
I've been coughing a lot.
I won't say my voice is dying.
I'm just still sick, so I'm still coughing.
So...
Anyway, guys.
Thank you everybody for coming.
Also, happy birthday.
Oh my gosh.
I didn't forget.
I'm sorry, I couldn't say happy birthday earlier.
Because I was in the middle of the game.
Who was it?
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Emo.
I'm so sorry if I pronounced your name wrong.
This happens a lot.
But yes, I didn't forget.
Happy birthday!
So...
I hope you guys all had a great time watching.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated, posh.
Check it out and move around to get that blood flowing.
And you stay up for me a bit.
Because you deserve it.
I'll be doing day two, so that's not tomorrow.
That's next week.
See you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!